if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is
[Music]
where there's tremendous amounts of
water where the water
[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Music]
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive
of the election what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
i just don't know about q anon you do
know
i don't know no i don't know you know if
you go out and you want to buy groceries
you need
a picture on a card you need id
he wants to host next year's g7 summit
at his
own doral golf club gotta take care of
the floors you know the floors of the
forest it's very important
frederick douglass is an example of
somebody who's done an amazing job and
is being recognized more and more i
noticed
ivanka trump the president's daughter is
sitting
in for the secretary of state
remember that incredible night with the
maps
and the republicans are red and that map
was so red
from suchin kendo kerr
to virot colleen trump tweeting
the new york times they are a true enemy
of the people
i think we have enough of an interview
here hope okay that's enough
let's go this russian bounty story we
have multiple sources saying
that trump knew all along i was there
for a tiny little short period of time
it was much more for an inspection there
was no problem during the day
and said quote crazy joe biden he
doesn't know me
but he would go down fast and hard
crying
all the way they'll go out and they'll
vote and they're gonna have to go and
check their vote by going to the poll
and voting that way
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once the state department
is emphasizing to world leaders
that they should stay at donald trump's
hotels and they say the noise causes
cancer you tell me that one okay
trump ordered robert mueller the special
prosecutor
be fired the factory policy is wear a
mask at all times
and trump puts on goggles but no mask
and we're building a wall
in colorado we're building a beautiful
wall
trump floated the idea of swapping
puerto rico for greenland the ramp that
i descended after my west point
commencement speech was very long
all right welcome everybody we're not
going to go through that entire thing uh
it is the rare weekend stream we are
bringing you
uh live from new richmond wisconsin
the frank speech rally um
it is an incredible event and this is
apparently the only stream they can't
even
size it correctly so like we can either
see the top of the shot or the bottom of
the shot i messed around with this for
20 minutes
even if i start zooming out like it does
i guess
okay that kind of helps a little bit but
not really like the difference between
zoomed in normally
and all the way out it's marginally
better like they can't
they just can't do anything they can't
do anything
and the lineup for this is
um join mike and his friends on saturday
june 12th in beautiful wisconsin to
rally together for free speech
um gates open at 9 00 a.m program at 11
10 that's central so that's you know 20
minutes from now
watch for the aerial banner plane prior
to the event
speakers live on stage mike lindell
diamond and silk charlie kirk brannon
howes chris cox dinesh d'souza
danielle d'souza and sheriff clark i
think that that was just sheriff clark
that we were looking at
and then yes donald trump will be part
of this event
delivering some kind of speech um
now it's interesting they use the term
in real time
rather than live and i wonder if there's
some significance to that
but um it's a it's a who's who
of wacky wacky stuff let's just listen a
little bit
to what like who is this guy what could
he possibly be talking about
oh the problem with having this zoomed
out is i can't even
calm or call them at 800. 506 9028 to
support all this
sport mike and his team mike paid for
all of this
these people behind me are here for free
you're watching frankspeach.com for
free celebrating free speech so you can
reward me all right
so we're going to keep an eye on it and
it's it's pretty wild i'm not going to
lie and just
just to celebrate what we're doing um i
will
we have created a new coupon code oh
hold on i've got to fix my twitch subs
thing
we have a new coupon code and that code
is mic pillow
50 which you can use for just a massive
discount and it's sort of like a middle
finger to the mic
pillow people uh but we we have done
that it's a big grift it's a really
really big grift
okay let's get into so many different
things people it's so great to be back
you know people wondering why there were
no streams last week
the reason why there were no streams
last week is explained in detail on
yesterday's bonus show i will tell you
it is because of an electrical issue
that i didn't even know could be a thing
it was a heretofore unknown electrical
issue that i didn't think was possible
but as a result of that there were no
streams during the last week and you can
find out the the the full story on the
friday june 11
bonus show um i do want to say thank you
to a few
people here oh who have uh subscribed
via twitch
combo carl mono drizzle the font
peg retail disciple gravis
cosmos geoventure
j.p de beaston already exists is number
eight
guitar goddess number nine so i do
appreciate everybody getting us kicked
off there
and uh okay let's just get right into a
bunch of different things i do have some
unban requests to adjudicate because we
haven't had a stream in a little while
when you are banned on twitch if you
want to
appeal that ban you can do so and i'm
going to adjudicate
three of these right now
um we are we are uh assembling here as a
court of unban requests
a user named come ally faithful
showed up in early may and said
don't you have enough money you greedy
jew rat
they were banned immediately their unban
request was simply
greedy rat that is a permaban
uh let's go to the next one here
user bluefeather
said hey david pakman can i be banned so
i can make a silly unban request
they were then banned their unban
request is
phil asked to be banned
so i could make a silly unban request
you and then you failed
i mean i won't make that perma for now
but it's like you you got what you asked
for and then you didn't even do it it's
almost like you're just wasting my time
um really weird all right and then a
user named big baller
uh showed up and said um
trump 2024 and then they were banned
i don't and then they said not sure why
i got banned now that's i don't you know
jaby we love you i
don't think that's that warrants a ban i
really don't just trump 2024
trump 2020 may be warrants a ban because
it's like it's over
but trump 2024 i'm going to adjudicate
that
unbanned you are back but if you do show
up and put trump 2024
you know a hundred times you're going to
be banned again banned again
ban again banned again
all right very good so we're caught up
as far
as unban requests go few super chats
coming in daniel says stream
gleam take your coffee with cream diana
sends a 10 british pound super chat and
says for the coffee fund
and chris bonucci says what are your
thoughts on maya wiley for new york city
mayor
if you were still in new york city would
you rank her number one
uh i i am not uh i don't know enough
about her to say
i don't know enough about her to say
let's check in briefly here
with what's going on at the rally
uh-huh okay now just to let you guys
know ahead of time
we may be kicked off twitch and face
youtube twitch and youtube and maybe
facebook for streaming this
if that happens it would be the biggest
hypocrisy from
frank's speech who says there it should
just be
speech let people speak broadcast people
speaking get voices out there don't ban
don't do this if we then were to get
banned
for for broadcasting this you will hear
from me my friends
you will hear from me my friends now i'm
kind of weirdly off center here i did
make some changes let's see if we can
put me back in the middle
there we go i think that's better
okay good um and claudio bautista sends
a 20
super chat saying only you were amazing
thanks claudio i appreciate that
uh okay if you're just joining us today
is the day for the frank speech rally in
new richmond wisconsin donald trump will
be speaking at this rally in what is
being described as real time it's not
being described as live
but it's being described as in real time
the full lineup as you can see here
includes mike lindell himself diamond
and silk
charlie kirk and then i basically
i don't know who brandon house is i
don't know chris cox dinesh d'souza i'm
familiar with i assume danielle d'souza
is his wife
and then sheriff clark is that crazy
racist sheriff
um who uh people i guess love because
he's i think he's black and racist i
don't really know
newsmax does not appear to be covering
this yet it really seems like the only
place where this is live
is on uh mike lindell's website
it's all crazy it's all really really
crazy so it's
it's all starting soon and in
celebration of this and by celebration i
mean
in the deep despair that the fact that
an event like this is happening
uh we have a uh one day coupon code mike
pillow50 mikepillow50 all one word
and you can use that at jointpakman.com
it's uh it's it's really
basically just a protest discount it's a
protest coupon code
um in protest of everything that is that
is going on here
maddie boomboom says mr pakman sir look
at that
religious symbolism mixed with the
american flag
um where is it did they did they put a
crow oh down in the lower left here yeah
they've got a cross
mixed with the flag it's all nuts guys
it's really really nuts
sunil mahwani asks if the trump speech
will be pre-recorded
maybe maybe that's why they say in real
time
um i also want to say thank you to blue
feather
as well as a danish joint
for subscribing via twitch i do have a
few
of these uh what we we call them 661
voicemails
this is the very homophobic uh
transphobic anti-semitic woman
i'm not doxing anyone by saying 661
there's millions and millions of people
with 661
phone calls uh area codes and it's not
even really 661. i'm just calling it
661.
let's listen to a couple and just see
what's going on
it's funny how in a society where people
are
condemning the rich and meanwhile
criminals are being
plastered on tv like idols and movie
stars and stuff like that
and it's just like we really think the
dead weight
are obviously criminals
people we should hate who do bad things
and it's obvious when we give them
all right let's move on to the next one
as far as like working in a society um
together with investments um i feel like
society has to start getting along
better and start having some sort of
like
philosophy and that's a good idea okay
let's continue
by the way each of these is a separate
three-minute voicemail that times out
um where people are being encouraged in
society um
where it's like um you know some people
are just deemed
to be you know where they're like trying
to make groups and just be thought of as
worthy
well i don't know what any of this is
about
here's another one david i was
researching about millionaires
about how they're unsuccessful or
something in society
and i'm really oddly like weirded out
on how people aren't like prepared
to um inherit their allowance
and how whoa i just don't know what
these are about
um let's just look at like one more
this one's something about race racism
hi um so
i was like researching about like this
neanderthal
um genetics i guess like africa
completely
is evolved um from neanderthal genome
all right that we're getting away from
that and let me see if there's just
anything else i guess that's really it
[Music]
um
let's see one more hi i was wondering if
you could kind of further explain
capitalism
i was thinking maybe capitalism could
create a society that's
less racist and maybe it's not
as economically
um useful all right
and then just one more
what about middle eastern women about
how i feel like there's not
um there's not enough like attention
on who they are as people or what
they're going through
and stuff like that i feel like they're
like a little bit more dehumanized
all right well that's interesting let me
see people asking about jimmy from
philly
i don't think i have any jimmy from
philly stuff um
let's see hey yes david backman
um a few weeks or a few days ago you
were mocking
uh former president trump about his
uh blog that he closed down and we
thought that was somehow funny
and well i just won't let you know he
still has an online presence
and he trolled joseph biden
uh and told him not to fall asleep
so i i don't know what the hell are you
talking about him closing the blog
he must have reopened another one and
perhaps you should check into and get
your facts
yep we will get into that we will get
into that um
and then eric from massachusetts
continues to troll
hey david what's up it's eric from
massachusetts um
how you doing i just wanted to tell you
uh check the constitution
uh article two section four
that's the answer you wonder about biden
will be removed and
that will probably happen on the 14th
the 14th of what
the 14th of this month the 14th month
since he left off it like what the 14th
of what
um oh there is something from jimmy from
philly hold on a second check this out
get me some philly wait david
uh regarding your uh video you just put
it out titled
the new a new whatever on climate change
climate change i can't
remember it's not really that important
because it's a stupid video
but you had to call the kid jimmy didn't
you
that hurts man these are i don't know
what he's taught these are real people
that exist in the world like how do you
even get dressed
oh man um
that might be it
uh your advocation for the san jose
gun insurance is absolutely ridiculous
how how do you like podcaster insurance
and i have insurance yeah we have
insurance what do you mean that
i have insurance i have you know
liability insurance
um i have uh
what insurance i've you know i've got uh
umbrella insurance
uh yeah that's fine i have insurance
that's good
that makes about as much sense in gun
insurance
as maybe having a insurance on a
refrigerator
or a ceiling fan most people's
refrigerators
are insured through either homeowners
insurance or
condo insurance or renter's insurance um
and also how many people are killed by
fridges every year
man just really weaponized ignorance out
there
all right so that's it as far as
voicemails go i do want to say thank you
to steve dupree who just signed up at
joinpackman.com
using the coupon code better21 remember
that there is a
massive special coupon code today on my
website the coupon code is mikepillow50
because of this event that we're we're
standing by for the mike pillow rally
with donald trump and all these people
um mikepillow50 you can use that coupon
code today only at joinpakman.com
and it's uh it's it's a really really
great thing
i also want to say thank you to 27 for
the twitch sub as well as
giant duck both of whom signed up
via twitch super chats are coming in let
me see here
kind of weird to place an illustration
of a device designed to torture people
to death
over the flag and calling themselves
patriots
uh what i don't even know what you're
talking about what is that what is that
a reference to
a torture device over the flag i don't
see that
chris says any thoughts on the amc saga
have you been to the movies i haven't
been to the movies in years
and i didn't follow the amc meme stock
saga too much we did do one
one bit of cover oh the cross itself oh
i see we did a bit of coverage on it on
the bonus show a week and a half ago
roberto says how many people are there
now and how many are expected
i don't know how many are expect i don't
know anything about how many people i
mean
i don't know how much of the crowd this
is it looks like it's about to start the
screen just went off let's listen a
little
bit
[Music]
i can't imagine billy joel wants
anything to do with this
billy joel should uh sue and demand it
stops right away
sammy says david what do you think makes
all the evangelicals fall over trump
like he's become jesus christ
well he claimed to be against abortion
and hillary was pro-choice that's
basically it and then
they just mostly voted for him thanks to
ragin tater
ragin tater just gifted 10 subs over on
twitch
i appreciate that very much um thank you
also thank you to rochelle smith
rochelle is the first person in history
to get a membership on my website with
the coupon code mikepillow50
rachelle is new member number 25 today
that might whenever i see that and it
says terms
50 off with coupon mic pillow 50. i just
laughed to myself it's really just
entertainment for me
um people asking for unban requests i've
already gone through them we've already
adjudicated
all unban requests nothing nothing
happening there
um is there another gnome chomsky
interview planned well no we just
interviewed him 10 days ago
how how soon do you want me to interview
him again i don't
i don't know but we have been pi oh by
the way speaking of tick tocks
we've been posting to tick tocks and um
i love this is um hold on what user is
this
this is omaha cat lady
she did a duet with our tick tocks post
this was fantastic check this out
starbucks uses
gay semen in their coffee to make it
taste
good where did that come from gays tend
to love other
each other's semen and it flavors up the
coffee they like to taste
it this lady cracks me up i had never
heard of
the north omaha cat lady she has a
gigantic following she's got half a
million followers on tick tocks
isn't that crazy anyway so i really like
that she uh
she did that and what else oh how is
pacman live going pacman live is going
well
the second channel is live it's called
pacman live
we dropped in our first four thousand uh
subscribers the pacman live channel
actually has clips from the streams
people who often miss the streams say i
want to see the highlights
it's really low lights but we don't have
room on the main channel so now we have
the second channel
and we'll put some of the tick tocks on
and uh pacman live yeah
davidpakman.compacmanlive
is how to find it um maybe moderators
can paste the link
in the chat on all these various
platforms
but it's it's going well and we're
headed to the first 5000 we've been
adding
more and more content and that is all
it's all great okay so that's pacman
live and
then what else i guess that's really it
we're mostly caught up on everything and
standing by for the frank speech
event um other super chats coming in
love the weekend streams thank goodness
for sadder david says anne
love it ferret says weddings in two
weeks rehearsal dinner tonight
wow isn't the rehearsal dinner usually
the day before super stressed thanks for
giving me a distraction to help me get
through it absolutely ferret queen
i don't know what sort of a schedule
you've got going there it looks like
mike pillow has arrived
let's uh take a listen it's starting
nice wide shot
everybody oh my god
we're getting we're going to get ready
to start with our national anthem but i
want to thank each
one of you for coming this day is going
to be a historical day
and historic first amendment rights of
free speech
first amendment rights of free speech
we're gonna i want to thank all the
media that showed up and i want to say
one thing where's fox
right you know
this is part of our council culture and
our free speech being suppressed yeah
you got fox who's supposed to be oh this
is the best
you can't even go on there and say
anything anymore it's disgusting
but um anyway we're going to talk about
a lot of that today
the people that you're the speakers we
having they've all been canceled like a
lot of you have whether
where our voices on youtube on vimeo
all these places in the mainstream media
where you can't talk about anything if
you say the wrong thing about
your faith or about machines or vaccines
or
machines they decide what you can and
can't say
the governor wisconsin at the governor
um
ron johnson the senator here in
wisconsin
right he just got
i think it was a seven day suspension
for saying talking about
hydroxychloroquine that they've proven
now did great
this is the best how shameful is that
they're even censoring us
after the fact right you know this is
horrible what's going on in our country
for free speech
free speech i just want we're going to
get started now i'm going to have
brandon come out here we're going to
sing the national anthem
it's going to be the best festival
you've ever seen
and i want to again thank you all for
coming god bless you
all right we will mute the national
anthem not out of disrespect but just
because
we we have so many other things to to
keep doing um
and and talking about and uh it's all
it's all happening this is going to be
crazy
i i do want to thank say thank you to
nag wrangler for gifting five subs as
well as jonesy
shattered relics dark warrior uh that is
that is eight additional folks who just
signed up there via twitch
and um i can't thank people enough using
the coupon code mikepillow50
sean raja just signed up on my website
with the code my
mic pillow 50. christine carson is a new
member at joinedpakman.com
with the coupon code mikepillow50
um one real quick thing people might
like here's a possible intro
wgbh style for the new pacman live
channel
tell me what you think about this i
think that this is cool
okay you guys like that that that's a
possible intro for the new channel i
think that that's interesting
um i wonder how long the e pill lasts
until he needs a refill
if you're on tick tock when do we see
some booty
it's great to see you covering these
atrocious disinformation rallies i can't
get enough of republicans making fools
of themselves nationally
by the way how long isn't the anthem
only like 90 seconds what is happening
here
[Music]
oh man i should have played it oh my god
and the home
of the brain
mike pillow is like davening like an
orthodox jew it's weird that's strange i
thought he was like evangelical
what a bizarre event
do you think they have fried dough and
cheese curds and stuff
okay you guys we got a little surprise
coming here
uh-oh that can't be good
wow what a crowd you guys are awesome
thank you again all for being here
you guys we're going to have some what
beautiful weather thank you god this is
amazing
yeah um
what a mess are they when are they
surprised in the sky here oh i guess
there's like four planes that are going
to fly over
30 seconds didn't get the timing quite
right
i'm not going to run for anything until
these machines are gone
right
[Music]
right
[Music]
oh sorry i do want to say thanks to
colin shea for signing up with the
coupon code mikepillow50
we have this nutty coupon code
mikepillow50 all one word all lowercase
at joinedpakman.com
in honor or horror of this guy
he's on mic he doesn't even seem to
realize it
from what i read he organized four
airplanes to fly over
[Music]
it says here a four plane military
flyover
and god bless america let's get my mic
out here we go would you join me singing
god bless america while we wait on this
surprise
they're stalling now because of the
surprise god bless
america america oh my god
i love stand
beside her and
guide her pure comedy through the night
with the light from above
from the mountains there is no better
entertainment than this
i mean what is funnier than this through
the oceans
wide with home
god bless america
now it's cutting my home
sweet home
[Music]
my home sweet home did he say boom
if you are here if you are here and you
served or are serving
in our armed forces would you please
raise your hand right now
would you join me in thanking whoa those
who are active
fbi take notice these are the folks to
keep an eye on in august
making it easy for our current law
enforcement
you please raise your hands
join me in thanking them for their
service god bless you america
if you are a first responder firefighter
emt
raise your hand will you please i guess
they're waiting for a flyover and it's
delayed i don't know
all right we are waiting on a flyover
yeah okay but we're gonna go ahead and
get
kurt landry up here he is the founder
who's that of kurt landry ministries and
he's going to open us
with prayer today oh no move your hats
if you would
all right welcome kurt landry i'll do
the songs but we're not we're not doing
the prayers that's just nuts so things
already kind of off the rails there's
supposed to be a four plane flyover and
smoke show of some kind um and it's
delayed and now they're bringing on
a pastor i guess thank you to pate2
for subscribing via twitch
um very much appreciate that they're now
they're now doing
prayers i guess i also want to say thank
you to brandy jackson brandy jackson
just dropped in
a huge membership using the coupon code
mikepillow50
mic pillow 50 is the today only coupon
code and brandy
just used it at joinpakman.com thanks
brandi i really appreciate that
um yeah it seems maybe rudy giuliani was
put in charge of the planes
and uh that he misunderstood and instead
of
boeing it's boing boing it's like a
paper plane company that does paper
planes it's really strange what's
happening um
jacob says serenade us brandon
vinnie dem says david i've been watching
your show since one six love you dude
speaking of one six i just reported
someone to the fbi for participating on
one six you rock
thank you i appreciate that jay harrison
rickert says
sorry david sending love no need to
apologize or at least i'm not aware of
why you're apologizing
i also want to say thank you to a betkey
a betke
just gifted 10 subscriptions via twitch
appreciate that um
[Music]
man this this is you just can't it
doesn't get any better that
i'm now curious about the prayer i agree
in prayer
i am not a politician i am a man of god
and the bible says genesis
and god said let us
make man in our image after our likeness
and let them have dominion right minion
is a good word dominion comes from god
uh-oh dominion is what jesus hung on
across
all right they're probably going in the
direction of talking about dominion
voting machines so we're going to get
away
with that away away from that jay
harrison says sorry for having to deal
with this crap brother okay i i
appreciate that that i appreciate
also i want to say thank you to ania
flanders who just signed up on
joinedpakman.com
with the coupon code mikepillow50
thank you so much ania i really
appreciate your support
as we are uh standing by for a flyover
that is what do you think of flyover
costs
anybody have an idea could it be a
hundred grand for a four plane flyover
i guess it depends on whether it's like
you know a cub
or like an actual jet plane i don't know
but could it could it be a hundred grand
for i think if it was um
i think if it was just like you know
propeller planes it would be cheap but
i'm guessing that's not
what mike pillow is doing joe rader asks
is this a political rally or a church
service
i can't tell yeah i really can't tell
what it is
um weird gospel
is spread with the word of god
and in revelation chapter 12 11 12 11.
they overcame him satan by the blood of
the lamb
and the word of our testimony we
are the soul winning nation we have led
more people to the lord jesus
is this all happening because they're
mad that trump lost like is that really
what this is all about
is is it is it just they're unhinged
because of that
are they telling this guy to just keep
going because the flyover is delayed
and it is not your time with your
antichrist spirit
to raise up and father god in the name
of yeshua
i speak like elisha over frank's speech
that all of those
who speak on frank's speech would be
able to speak the inspired words
would you say amen they would be able to
speak the truth would you say
amen they would be able to bring
creative revelation would you say amen
and here's my prayer it's in the book of
john chapter one
amen man all these books he's all he's
genesis revelation the book of john
um hard to even keep all of this stuff
straight
yeah this has got to be a lawsuit
waiting to happen right
joseph says waiting for hugo chavez to
press the cringe button on those
machines
i'm waiting for dr eric coomer to speak
i think that that'll be happening soon
thanks to life is good as well as
wood for now you're not going to get me
with that wood
for signing up on twitch as well as 13
hours by time machine
and nz cassie that puts us
at uh 53 today
uh standing by for a flyover thanks to
timothy goolsbee who just signed up on
my website with the coupon code
mikepillow50
suzanne bateman also just signed up with
the coupon code
mikepillow50 do not adjust your tv
this really is so poorly produced that
the lighting is a disaster
and you can't even see the entire screen
at once we're doing the best we can
the absolute best we can um all right i
guess this guy is done now
of jesus christ would you say amen
if you'd say these words after me in
jesus name
we bless frank's speech
to be the salt and light
and the voice for our nation maybe the
flyover is canceled
we will not look back
we will not be silenced
god says in his word
let the redeemed of the lord's
this is so anybody who would find this
like
oh we're here for a cool thing but it's
delayed
oh yeah they this is fun though i like
what this guy is doing like
it's just mindless mindless um
big thank you to ian jarraz for signing
up on my website with the coupon code
mikepillow50
also thanks to colin lundqvist for
signing up with the coupon code
mypillow50. that coupon code is is
titillating people that's for sure
um i get i don't even know what we're
waiting for now
uh okay someone's coming back on stage
thank you pastor all right folks we had
some of our military
air force veterans that were going to do
a flyover for us they still may be
making it but we have
that schedule it's not happening that's
the best
they just can't find the planes and our
first they're gone
speakers today really need no
introduction we all know them we all
love them
fly over cancelled diamond and sill
will you please join me in welcoming
diamond
and sil
i hope everybody's ready for this
standing ovation for diamond and silk
americans make some noise
oh they're untangling the mics i like
that my goodness i am so
happy to be here in wisconsin i love you
all
thank you so much wisconsin dale he is
truly a patriot
you all give it up for michael and damn
is the format that one of them just does
hype i want you all to know that we are
in the united states of america
not the united states of china but the
united states
of america i like that guy's shorts who
just walked by refused to accept
communism socialism and marxism
please define those diamond or silk i
don't know which is which
we stay in the land of the free and the
home
of the brave not slaves
right now y'all know why we're here
i actually don't know like somebody
wants to silence
our freedom of speech that's what it
seems like
but we can't let that happen thank god
for frank's speech
[Music]
maybe somebody could explain why we're
here i don't know they don't want us
talking about
some things when it comes to this 2020
election that's right
they keep telling us that we can't call
it election fraud
but what they want us to call it they
borrowed the election
well if you borrowed it how about you
give
it back i don't know that the one on the
right really even needs a microphone
you know i really don't understand the
left they ran around for
four years pushing russia collusion
and election interference for four
years four years and then after the
election of 2020
when we say something they want to call
it an
insurrection right those crazy people
direction we want election
[Music]
man
and sometimes with the left because
everything goes
over their head you got to start at the
bottom at the bottom baby
a lot of these people took an oath to
uphold the constitution
which people the first question is was
constitutional laws broken
the crowd would know that for sure this
is a crowd that knows constitutional law
some voter irregularities
and possibly i'm sorry i'ma have to call
it like it is diamond
voter fraud
so you all know they're doing these
election audits across
the country in arizona and other places
yes i know y'all like that type of
transparency
yeah and all of a sudden now the
attorney general
announced here is what he said i want to
make sure i quote it
quote that the justice department will
scrutinize
any post-election audits for evidence of
voting
law violation but they wouldn't let
us scrutinize the 2020 election
but they want to scrutinize the artist i
have a problem with that a big problem
with that
oh yeah
okay because we don't need the doj
scrutinizing anything
what you should have been doing was
looking into
what happened in 2020 that's right
[Music]
that wind feels so good blowing silk i
love it yes
wow this crowd's really energized
they're ready to do some activism
things have been happening in our
country you all uh-huh
and they want us to think that we are
divided but let me tell you something we
are the united states of america
yeah well port-a-potty's in the
background you gotta love that
and i have a bone to pick with some
people and i don't want nobody to get
offended
but i have a ball to pick with some of
our republicans there's way more people
watching my stream than are actually
there
because how can you say you stand for
the constitution
you stand up for the american people and
you take and you hand
our country over to these left-leaning
radicals does silk do anything other
than hype
now they have a problem with
us doing this audit the forensic audit
well forensic to the left since you all
certified now it's time for us to
verify that's what we need to do
amen
and there's nothing wrong with voter
transparency
that's right we need some voter
transparency
that's right now everybody is all upset
uh-huh
you have a patriot like mike lindell
standing on the front line
where is the rnc where you're at rnc
where is the gop where you act gop
wow they're really making a compelling
case asking us
for what i don't know for us if you
can't fight for
[Applause]
us
[Music]
if you can't fight for we the american
people
i don't plan to give you not one there's
not a single black person in the crowd
right
not one
i will be donating my money directly to
donald j trump
[Applause]
if you want money go get it from paul
ryan uh-huh
mitch mcconnell uh-huh mitt romney
uh-huh
liz cheney uh-huh but don't try to come
off of
the american people and you would stand
up
for the american people
right he had to get that on off my chest
and to alejand omar
the only thing i can tell you all uh-huh
if you don't like this country
if you have a problem with the united
states of america
you can leave
[Applause]
i mean wouldn't that that apply to all
of them who don't like biden
then why don't these folks leave now
that's right
when you come into the united states of
america
you need to assimilate to our ways
not your way
[Applause]
it's getting pretty xenophobic guys
what are you crazy tell me we need to
defund the police
we need our police officers to protect
and to serve
[Music]
and let me go head on and get this off
my chest too so
go ahead on and get it off your chest
too i need to sue black lives matter
[Music]
[Laughter]
is there any different organization who
do you sue and follow this
foolishness that they've been pushing in
this country that's right
and stop talking about this critical
race theory
uh-huh it's a theory right
yeah as far as i'm concerned it's a
conspiracy theory
[Applause]
oh man because you know any time me and
you
say something silk they always saying we
spreading conspiracies
well you are what happens when it turns
out to be a fact
jack
you know you are they trying to divide
us we can't let that happen no we cannot
we can't let that happen so bond is
talking about he
building back better but it looked like
he's
building back she's attacking half the
republican party and saying the other
side is trying to divide them
borders that's wide open that should be
shut
to illegal aliens that's right
and please stop telling me they are
immigrants
a immigrant get in line and wait their
turn
[Music]
an illegal alien comes in illegal how
long could this possibly go on
to my house and you break in you are a
burglar not a guest that's right
[Music]
somebody need to go tell biden and his
regime that
uh-huh i heard he over there overseas
what is she talking about
i can tell he's leading from the back
cognitive decline walking in the back
leading from the back mumbling words he
looked pitiful
not the video i saw
and it's so sad that that's leading our
country
and what you're not going to do you left
the media
you not gonna lie to me and tell me
that biden had more black people to vote
for him
than the black president you're not
gonna get me to believe that
that's the
and if y'all don't believe me all you
have to do is go walk in the hood
and start asking questions
but the oh the left they don't want you
imagine being at this like i'd be really
examining my life if i was there
that's what they're gonna say no it's
not conspiracy theory
it's critical imagine leaving and being
like wow that was really great in the
basement in the basement the whole
campaign
half sleep couldn't get a crowd to show
up
[Music]
no i'm sorry you didn't win no election
it looked like y'all may have stolen an
election
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's my humble opinion i can have
an
opinion because the constitutional right
tells me
that i have a right to freedom of speech
no one's taking it away what you're
saying is idiotic that's there's going
to be consequences which will be
people think you're dumb and we
black women in this country uh-huh we
can speak
isn't that identity politics don't bully
us into a corner no you're not
that's identity politics isn't it camera
scanning for black people in the crowd
you're not gonna do that let me tell you
something when people from venezuela
and cuba come to this country yeah they
come to this country
because they have a place to run to
if we as americans do not stand up
against this tyranny
where are we going to wait so
immigration is good or bad we have no
place to rock
and get it because the united states is
the greatest
country
this event is making me doubt that i'm
questioning whether that's true
[Music]
these people want to radicalize our
children
they want to radicalize the college
students they want you to go along with
the radicalization
you should say hell no to jim
crow joe whoa
[Applause]
that's pretty pretty strong there
now forgive me for my little cousin but
you know hell is in the bible yes it is
oh yeah i'm just all of them can she's
got to be to the end of her nose
tired of this yeah and i want to sue the
whole government
yes yes yes sue everybody you look sat
here
uh-huh we're in the midst of a pandemic
uh-huh we don't gain all of this covet
weight
all of this what do you think they get
paid for this
eight thousand each maybe what's his
name girl got the flip flop saucy
has been under covering and
flip-flopping on the american people
and let me just say this i'm not an
anti-vaccine
uh-oh you do whatever you have to do
for your family that's right but how
dare you try to bribe
me with a burger and a french fry and
tell me
i need the sticks now they're against
businesses offering stuff how dare you
yeah
what
we still stay in the united states of
america that's right
if you want this to be the united states
of china
then take your behind to china but this
is the united states of america does
china bribe people with burgers
is that what they're saying
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know nothing about no communism
no we don't
that's clear nothing about no socialism
that now that's true nothing about no
marxism
you know nothing about it i know
now i don't know what these people
trying to push
you got the black life matter movement
want to emasculate our men
want to get rid of the nuclear family
pushing to defund the police
how is that gonna help us as americans
anybody need a mercy ban
and then you fly in those flags on
our embassy the only flag that should be
flying on any embassy here in the united
states
is the united states american flag
that's it
i guess this is real yeah
not the united states of black lives
matter
that's right strong statement
in this country all of our lives matter
you have black lives white lives
hispanic lives native american lives
all of our lives matter
now for some of you all if you don't
like the united states of america
how about you go build yourself an
island uh-huh
and move over there with that
foolishness that's right
but here we're united that's right and
let me just say this y'all uh-huh
i know you all think this is just about
politics
but really this is about our freedom how
do you wrap a speech like this
and what i'm telling people drop the
politics for a minute that's right
it's time that we get on the same side
as america as americans we need to be on
the same side
that's right i don't care whether you
are a conservative
or a liberal a republican or a democrat
it's time to get on the same side
because if not
we're not going to have any freedoms
this is like the most divisive screed
and she's saying we need to be united
and then you have these people trying to
silence our voice
now i don't know what the zuck is up
with mark zuckerberg
are they trying to pull them off the
stage and he's sucking with the wrong
two
black women more identity politics i
don't know guys it's weird
it's almost like they're not really
against identity politics if it helps
them
we have a right to think for ourselves
that's right
we have a right to think outside of the
box that's right
we can be conservative i can be
a republican i can stand up for what's
right
and nobody including mark zuckerberg
have no right to try to silence us
that's right
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
don't let these people get away with it
they tried to brand us because of what
happened
on january the 6th uh-huh they tried to
deem everybody as white supremacists
diamond and silk is two black women and
they even called
are they admitting some of the rioters
were white supremacists are they
admitting that
and the last art chat i'm fully black
from the crowd of
[Applause]
this has got to be satire this can't be
real
[Music]
don't you let them do it don't get it
twisted honey i don't have a problem
with letting these democrats know
you the one created the white supremacy
that's right you don't want created the
kkk
yes you're the one brought in jim cross
and i don't let them live or die no we
don't now i know the left on too much
care
but diamond is silk but i could care
less that's right
you couldn't care less you couldn't care
less
and frank's speech but like in the words
of a famous
person frankly i don't give a damn
they're really moving forward the
discussion on american politics
with the way our country is going yeah
and i'm looking at the republican
and the democrat party it looks like
it's one dirty bird
with two corrupt wings and we got to get
rid of
the corruption that's right wow
yes yes yes yes yes oh my god she has
more pages
and moves to 2022 until we
solve what happened in 2020 come on
and i know we was all on the trump train
but it's sad when you have your
own trying to derail the train that's
right
that's what bothers me with all of this
uh-huh don't let them bully you into a
corner
we are americans you all we still
stay in america right do we not
well you have to act like it
these people taught us with words they
bully us yeah they call us names they
demonize
us they marginalize us and they think we
supposed to sit back
and take it and take it we don't have to
take it
we can speak out against this tyranny
that's right
what biden is doing to america what is
he doing
destroying it i don't even think the
audience is actually entertained by this
and they seem to be dying out talked
about putting americans first
people thriving yeah people coming up
yeah
and now look at what's happening you got
people sitting around
collecting welfare and they calling it
stimulus
you got bodies you say simba's like from
the lion king did you say simba's
all of these jobs no jim crow joe
you ain't creating one job one job
stop giving these people money to sit
down
and allow them to go back to work
[Music]
what
i just don't know what to say about this
this is not a presidency to me this is a
regime
a regime he was installed by the swamp
is silk taking over now not elected
by the people
[Applause]
i guess they go to silk now they don't
want you to talk about that
but they ran around for four years
pushing russia
russia russia russia and the only thing
i knew about russia
was that russian dressing that i put on
my corned beef sandwiches that's right
unless they want to talk about that time
where i ran my pressure up from eating
some poke sausage and everything on the
tv look russian
diamond we call that a reuben please
oh you are sometime i have to laugh to
keep from crying
me too because this is so disappointing
to me
because when you have your own throw you
under the bus
that's a problem president trump didn't
deserve
any of this that's right what they're
doing to him
and i want you all to understand the
media
is also in on this as well the media
yeah that includes fox 2.
right gary auntie fox today
and i'm tired of these people lying to
the american public
how about you come clean that's right
how about you let the american people
know
what's really going on do it
you don't have to prance around barack
hussein
obama he's already been the president
he's no longer the president
why is he still talking why why is trump
by that logic at this event
and he had the nurse the other day to
say something about this critical race
theory
oh my god i think it's making the white
people feel uncomfortable
um i'm sorry it's also making black
people feel
uncomfortable too because you all are
trying to push
segregation that's what you're trying
to do that's right
go ahead girl isn't barack hussein obama
biracial that's right
right his father is black so do he feel
like his white side is oppressing his
black side
please list the races of more people
feeling like a victim because of his
white stuff
none of this makes any sense no sense
let me tell you all
something uh-huh we know what happened
in our country
people in the crowd taking notes yeah oh
that's true yeah 50
right right keep focusing on what
happened back in the 1800s
why do we have to go back a hundred
years
if you gonna go back a hundred years how
about you talk about
what happened in the summer of 2020
when businesses was burned to the ground
when
businesses was looted when people
livelihoods
has been taken from them destroyed
no you can't let them get by with it you
can't let them get
by with it let me tell you something
president trump was the greatest
president that we've ever seen
in our lifetime
man can we get up
maybe a contest going on twitch about
how much longer this will go
people want to bet maybe a moderator can
set it up
i mean just this one speech
and people keep asking us people smartly
covering themselves from the sun now if
you're out for four hours
in the sun during this stuff you will be
burned to a crisis
in our country right now is
unprecedented we've never
had anything like this to happen before
that's true and what i keep telling
people is to pray
do you all still believe in the power
of prayer right
now what about just praying for trump to
have won before wouldn't that have been
smarter
see if you have faith as a grain
of a mustard seed come on you can talk
to that mountain
that's that moment you say a grain of
mustard seed will
be was that the analogy a grain of
mustard seed
[Applause]
we don't know what's gonna happen uh-huh
but you have to let the
button unfold let it unfold so first
we're starting with these
forensic audits and here's my theory
what's your theory
why don't you auto out of the whole
election
everything that's right do that do the
whole thing
come on i have a question for you okay i
noticed how the democrats
is trying to interfere in the
certification
of the audit what the election's been
over for seven months
when you try to block the certification
so my question is if they're trying to
interfere
in the artist in arizona for example
does that make them an insurrection
because they're trying to stop
the verification of the certification
of jib tailgating let me think about
that that's a tough question
good way of look at that again
what are they trying to hide what does
it mean to certify an
audit by the way what they trying to
hide but look like somebody gonna get
caught real soon
that's right yeah
if the jewish space lasers exist they
should be used to destroy the audio
equipment
right now at this event no don't run
there and i know it didn't pick up no
balance from the graveyard no
no and the graveyard don't have internet
services no
so i wonder how many dead people voted
nothing you got to be cautious dead
people can't vote
that's why i said i wonder that's my
opinion
[Laughter]
they'll fact-check you and say that's
wrong uh-huh you should say no stuff
like that uh-huh but it's my opinion
and why can i have an opinion about
these dead
votes coming in in the 2020 election
allegedly
my opinion well listen we know the dead
in christ
rose but the dead in christ didn't rise
for bodies no it didn't
do that no it didn't no i won't believe
it
are they winding down see still that's
why they don't like us
because we try to think logically
about the whole thing that's right we
don't just sit back and accept anything
i i if if we can stand to miss 30
seconds of this i do want to say thank
you to people who have been supporting
the stream daniel
larson as well as leurdon and wickedness
as well as hack phooey tool man
tim big foot tornado two hot nelly
and dollar batteries all signed up
putting us at 65.
also i do want to thank everybody taking
advantage of the one day coupon code
mikepillow50
karen colvin just signed up on my
website using the code mypillow50
john eilingworth signed up melinda pegg
raquel vasquez and david mcdonald all
taking advantage of the coupon code
mikepillow50
a celebration of a true horror taking
place
right now listen if we don't get this
together that's right
all of us are going to be slaves i don't
care whether you black
white pinstripe polka dot or a plan
we all going to be playing food around
up here that's right
these people are trying to bankrupt this
country yes
they are they're giving out all of this
money you all
and we don't have nothing to bag it up
do you think they get paid by the minute
maybe
see i can see if we had a pot of money
somewhere uh-huh
but ain't no pot so what you just doing
print money
like it's monopoly money and giving it
away
just giving it away food cost is going
up uh-huh
i got to tell the story go ahead on and
tell them i love
mangoes mangoes my bag of mangoes up
under trump cost me eight dollars
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our body's
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three bucks each
that's i want what eight or 11 bucks
that sounds good then the american
people
belie it's highway rivalry is what
you're doing that's right
bring my mangoes back down that's right
right about the wisconsin crowd not
identifying with the mango material
proportionally affected
don't raise the price of fruit don't you
want me to be
healthy don't you now that ticked me off
when i went to the grocery store
the other day and i said somebody's got
to be sold for this
do they know kiwi pricing i would love
to know what what are kiwis costing
these been around with these people yeah
and what they've done is politicized
this pandemic
and got everybody just in a hoop line
that's right don't know whether they
coming or going uh-huh
take the jab don't take the jab wear the
mask don't wear the man
if you didn't get a vaccine you sit over
here if you got your vaccine
you sit over there segregation these
people
bring back segregation these people are
trying to go back to this
oh man these people are trying to bring
back jim crow day
yeah do they want socialist price
controls good questions
we have to stand up
[Music]
the government's got to set prices on
vegetables and fruits
determine the price of mangoes set the
price
of mangoes this is america
[Applause]
this ain't no third world country
somebody go let aloha
oh my no allah
[Applause]
they're just repeating the speech again
and i got one more thing
beef they're gonna have to get our get
their hands off our bay
address strawberries though teaching
them inappropriate
nasty foolishness at
six years old take your hands
off of our children you should hear
their rant about dragon fruit if you
think the mango stuff was wild
and take these masks off of
our children
[Applause]
there is a foul spirit that has creeped
into the united states
they found a seed in a seedless grape
recently and they want joe biden to do
something about it properly
talk to our children about masturbation
and all of this other foolishness you
are a
foul spirit take your hands off of our
children
[Applause]
they also believe canned vegetables are
a scam
compared to frozen babies they don't
know no battle
[Music]
you nasty we're the pastors that's right
we're the preacher says where are you
why ain't nobody standing up for our
babies
they're all standing up they don't know
why but they're standing up you're
grooming
our children for your own pleasure take
your damn hands
off of our children ban masturbation but
set prices on mango
[Applause]
now if you don't want to get me upset
don't mess with the baby
are people cheering for masturbation or
for banning it
i can't tell you i am so tired of this
progressive
left-leaning liberal radicalism uh-huh
can't keep your hands off our church
that's right
[Music]
listen you all it's not only an attack
on our freedoms
but they want to get our babies yeah as
young as they can get them yeah
because they know the adults ain't going
along with their nasty
sick sinister we can't allow these
people
to take the minds of our baby babies and
corrupt them
and to make them into something that
they're not
why won't they stop don't let anybody
take away their innocence that's right
when you hear them talking about this
critical race theory
and all of these books they want to
start them young knowing about stuff
that i don't think that they should know
about is inappropriate
you need to let them know take your
hands off of
our babies take them off our church
that's right
oh there's a foul spirit you can't tell
me
81 million people voted for this
foolishness
it's a lie and a true thing in it that's
right so i had to get that off my chest
don't mess with our babies don't mess
with our elderly
and think oh this is another one come on
let me tell you something tell it
i mean i can't say it no more uh-huh
cuomo
oh oh oh my god i thought this was going
in a different direction
oh yeah he don't deserve a book deal
he deserves deserve a prison sale
with no deal you don't take
and you don't place covet 19 patients in
with our elderly
and kill them up that's right because
that's what you did
kill them crimes
against humanity and he needs to be
jailed for that not praised for it
that's right
listen i'm glad you called out the
governors uh-huh
any one of them that pushed these
draconian measures uh-huh with their
feet on people next uh-huh making them
stay locked down
taking their business you know feed on
neca folks
a memory of something that happened
which they didn't seem to care about
i love you all right you want to be free
you want to man free the crowd of the
speech come on
end it for freedom
[Applause]
please free the crowd from the bondage
of this speech
now i know that they tried to derail the
trump training
but i'mma say it like this are we all on
the trap train
yeah i said are we all
on the trump train
when i say all aboard you say choo-choo
all aboard
[Music]
[Applause]
god bless the united sheish
wow and after all of this it is
finally finally over an
absolutely brutal assault on everything
that is kind and decent
wow all right our next speaker here
today is chris cox let me tell you about
him
2013 the government got shut down
right okay while he does this i do want
to make sure i'm keeping up with
thanking there's a lot of great people
supporting the stream and i appreciate
it
thanks to am 615 as well as jilted
passion and lorimer
deeper shades of house uh great to see
you
as well as a gift and a sub from nia
masters
that six space robot four thousand has
signed up that is seven putting us at 77
and really exciting the coupon code mike
pillow which is a meme code
is off the charts james rigal has just
signed up at joinpackman.com
matthew michael has just signed up trish
brazil just signed up with the coupon
code mikepillow50
and jason willowby just signed up with
the coupon code mike pillow50 that's a
today only code okay
joinpakman.com coupon code mikepillow50
saves you a lot
um the the super chats i can't even keep
up but some of them were having me
laughing out loud in my mind sunil says
sounds very cute and ani
a soccer player just died on the field
that's not good news
okay we'll get to that later terrible
speech didn't even address banana prices
i know it's like
they you can i want to know why are all
fruits
of the price that they are why is kiwi
down why are bananas up i don't know
all right let's continue
what is this guy wearing and how tall is
it
who is this guy
[Music]
so yeah um chris cox i'm the founder of
bikers for trump and we exist
okay we've seen donald trump president
we've had our work cut out for us here
lately there's been an assault on
decency
the left is coming after your bibles
your bullets
and your babies and if you don't stand
up
and make and make a difference now it's
going to be too late soon
he should do a conversation with ron
perlman
everybody out there right now you
are political activist for the fact that
you're here today you're not home
watching on tv you're making it well
it's not on tv and that's what it's
about it's about standing up
even when no one else does you stand up
you don't even know why you stand up you
know
but you do it was it that long ago what
made
this country so great for we the people
were the institutions that we put our
trust in
the institutions that have consistently
led us down here lately
you know we think about the fbi for one
right
the fbi and their misguided um collusion
investigation yeah this is low-rent
ron perlman from sons of anarchy when
did the fbi lose sight
when did they start protecting us
instead of setting us up
i might tweet that actually i like that
let me see giuliani's house being
invaded
by under the dark of night okay
meanwhile we've had ant from black lives
matter burning down
cities across the country
it's pathetic and we've got to make a
difference here
we look at the cdc under falci
under this with this plan demik if you
will and
how it sabotaged our last election
okay there's no way that
joe biden got 80 million votes folks no
way
donald trump could gather he could be
getting gas at a gas station have more
people show up and and want to shoot oh
my god
look at the trump thing there on the
stick
[Music]
we look at the fake news
when did when did it get so polluted
when did they start pushing their own
narrative there
perpetuating it and trying to brainwash
america
when did they stop reporting on the
facts the who the when and the where
and how are they surviving you look at
cnn as crash by the way cnn do you see
what last year where they reported that
i was dating both diamond and silk
i mean come on
they have no clue you're exactly right
you know this voting system here in the
shenanigans that are going on
god bless the hard work in manicope
county how let's hear it for those guys
[Applause]
unbelievable what's happening
and from there i'm hoping they come here
to wisconsin or they go into georgia
you know we think about some of the work
that the bikers for trump have done and
we've led the country in voter
registration
our bikers have apps on their phone
these are the top biker voter
registration people
it'll check your registration and if you
have any problems we can fix it on the
spot
we can register you on the spot or if
it's a state that doesn't provide
online registration we can have that
information
sent to your doorstep maybe states
should just provide online registration
which they're against
you know another one of the
accomplishments of the bikers for trump
there's a demographic that was untapped
it was almost
impossible to get to took me four years
to get in there with them
when i first got there they thought i
was a blowhard but what i did wouldn't
leave they started taking me serious
it's the amish
the amish who have traditionally never
voted
who are told not to vote but see
the the amish were never affected by
these recessions and when donald trump
got in office they had more
18 wheelers going out of ohio and
pennsylvania than ever before
it's the top biker app for registering
amish voters
of all apps the toughest and the
rowdiest demographic of all the bikers
were the ones able to
harness the amish the most religious and
docile
docile what the hell we were doing the
man
what are the animals one county home
they've domesticated the oven a lot of
people think the most amish are in
pennsylvania that's not true
they're in ohio that's why it started
there wayne and holmes county 74 000
just in those two counties so
in holmes county with the work that the
bikers for trump did
we added an extra 7 500 votes in just
that one county
okay for donald trump not only did they
get the amish to vote they got him to
clean up after themselves like what the
hell is this guy talking about
lots of counties across this country
that are inundated and covered with
amish
so that's just littered with amish
everywhere that we added
between two like an infestation of amish
this guy would have
did anybody remember on the news when in
philadelphia where they dropped an extra
two or three hundred thousand votes
there in the middle of the night at four
o'clock in the morning is that true the
entire amish population is 270k
they didn't predict that the amish would
turn out like they did and they had to
cover their butts and those machines
were smoking
printing out those bags the total amish
population is 270. many of those are
kids
are not a security force oh my god
this also won't back down the um
now while i'm saying that i'm on this
topic if there's any black lives matter
is there any antifa
you spend your first damn bullet in my
chest okay because we're not scared of
you
and there'll be plenty of patriots to
step up and take my place i get it
[Music]
wow wow
so when they started to uh try to
impeach donald trump there in that last
little
misguided uh that escalated quickly yeah
we started the draft donald trump 2024
campaign yeah who turned down this event
i see him here in 2021
but we've got over 200 000 signatures i
believe at this point if anybody would
like to sign
bikersfortrump.com you can sign that
petition very easily it's the only thing
on that page
and we'll be presenting these uh these
signatures to the president
uh donald trump very soon the president
donald trump you know when we look at
these elections
clarify i'm from the great state of
south carolina
we have six of our seven congressional
members our republican our governor's
republican our two senators are
republican
okay that doesn't mean we don't have
problems right
no in fact it's because of it who voted
for impeachment
okay i'll be heading back to south
carolina to throw a rally in myrtle
beach with the bikers and we're
we're going to serve fried rice because
that's what we expect to do to tom rice
we're going to fry them i'm actually
really good at making fried rice i've
got a great recipe another female
representative that went on the one
thing i've tested with the thing that's
tough with fried rices
i found that if the peanut the i'm sorry
the toasted sesame oil is a key thing
with fried rice i used to do
sesame oil and butter the butter flavors
it too much
and it takes away from the sesame oil so
now i do a mix of sesame
and a neutral oil like canola has
dramatically scaled up my fried rice in
these
elections across the country especially
interest groups
groups like club for growth action and
prosperity for america
prosperity for america is run by the
koch brothers they give money to
democrats and republicans
so toasted sesame oil is the key
absolutely when they get on board and
say that they get behind
daled rice 40 candidates with a couple
million dollars each okay i'm with you
only 15 of them win now we've got
the club for growth and prosperity for
america which are tied to the koch
brothers the koch brothers are calling
policy shots now
and the house of representatives right
okay
they are deep embedded into the fabric
of our political system
and we've got to get rid of those guys
if we're going to clean the swamp and we
hear the president talk about cleaning
the swamp
but until we get rid of that washington
money polluting
these these congressional and these
senate races we're not going to be able
to do it
because when they give these millions of
dollars then they've got their hooks in
these freshmen candidates
and then boom they're calling shots
because they owe favors
we should not be allowed to give
candidates money before until after a
primary
okay that money pollutes elections
that money prevents other candidates
that may be qualified from having their
messages get out there
yo well
better late than never that was like a
single propeller plane wasn't it that's
not a flyover
so um that's what we got to do folks
when you're watching these candidates
here in the state and if you're in your
prospective state
look and see who's giving them money you
may like them but then you seek
prosperity for america club for growth
giving them money that's the coke
brothers will be pulling their streams
so
koch brothers are bad now i guess right
we got to be informed
we can't rely on mainstream media
they would rather our country crash then
prosper because of their narrative
because they're so warped
they're snowflakes and rainbows and
cupcakes and they just don't get it
all right
so um he i i've not really ever been
introduced people talking about that a
2013 event so
i'm in a nutshell so uh the government
shutdown in 2013
under barack obama which i would offer
later they wanted to put one of those
little yellow ribbons on my neck
for the work i did and i didn't want
obama touching me after he just had his
hands around michelle
okay so i turned it down
it might have helped me last year my
congressional race if i'd had it i had
that from a democrat but i'd rather not
had it
and they knew it and i made it very
clear because you see folks again if you
don't stand for something you'll fall
for anything
nice lying and to me you know the bikers
for trump you know
it's about open channel communication is
it possible this guy's racist like
maybe maybe your job is to bring people
to the lord
okay well the preacher does not
measure his life at the end of each
sermon
he measured it at the end of his life
right how many people did i lead to god
over my life
how many people can you lead to
conservative movement
over your life and way we do it is
through our example
it's through that open challenge
communication it's where people can look
and say what makes you tick
why do you believe the way that you
believe and then you can back it up with
fact
the fact that matches with the example
that you set
and that's what people will pay
attention to because most of americans
are
they're not informed yeah that's true
they need to be informed
you know when we think about this
election
and how we go to bed and donald trump's
up by millions of votes
and then we wake up and we're all just
bewildered
wow okay that's a hard one to swallow
but yet mainstream media and the
democrats mitigate this political
climate
through innuendo allegation circumstance
a friend who heard it from a friend they
read things on bathroom walls and then
they call for investors that's democrats
who do that
don't you think that we deserve some
answers what happened on november 6th
we certainly do so i was telling you so
the government shut down and i was in
washington dc i'm an artist i'm a
chainsaw artist i was there on an art
show and
so i knew there was nobody out there oh
man
i filled my backpack up i had a football
frisbee my beach cruiser i thought i was
gonna see a bunch of patriots out there
and
when i got out there i was the only one
you could hardly throw the frisbee to
yourself
so um i was just patrolling the uh the
grounds making sure nobody spray painted
because it was only like a year before a
chinese woman had spray painted or threw
some green paint
paint on lincoln oh a chinese woman oh
okay i wrote the n-word
on red paint on the front of the lincoln
memorial um
years before that someone went in and
poisoned a bunch of the trees there the
cherry blossoms and so my fault my job
was just going to be to
have my cell phone make sure that nobody
was going to vandalize it
right and then on the third uh the
morning the third morning
i'm walking back to my car and when i
got to the trash can that leads into
the uh the the wall there someone had
put a recyclable item in the trash can
it was horrible step
uncle's on there and i'm sure many of
your relatives are on there
the trash can had overflowed and it was
like two trash cans beside it and i'm
talking about spit
cups and diapers and um and rotten
tomatoes and i mean oranges and apples
and it was nasty
mangoes anything halfway home i'm
staying in octaquoin halfway i felt a
shame
i went to walmart got a bunch of trash
bags bought a dolly i went back and
that's when i became instead of security
i became the janitor
and um it wasn't 700 trash cans a day
but it's about 700 total
so i would just remove it from the
property because we had media from
around the world taking pictures
is it interesting to talk about how
trash is dealt with at
a park like a block away i had a big
belt in the trash
and then um the veterans were coming in
um
bedouins a week or ten days later so i
guess about 13 days into it
did you say bedouins they're a little
push mower like israeli bedouins were
there the memorial which is a pretty big
field and they came and they wanted to
they took it from me and and uh they
were going to write me a ticket that's
that the other but by then someone had
went by and they
oh veterans veterans around the world in
like 45 seconds
and um you know it's quite an experience
so
i stuck around when it was done and i
petitioned congress
and explained to him that we should not
allow these memorials
to just go wayward if the government
shuts down so i devised a plan
a plan that would allow veterans to come
up and take care of it
a plan that would allow the boy scouts
of america
is this basically about trash management
like what are we talking about here
we call it the memorial militia what
on earth i was later able to convince
congressman daryl lysa to help me
help me with the framework of the bill
and we named it the monuments protection
act
i had to introduce with bipartisan
support of the citizen
legislator the bill reads that the
secretary of agriculture
and the secretary of interior will enter
into agreement with
bikers against trash bags or for them i
don't know continued operation of an
open air war memorial public lands or
parks
during a lack of appropriations or for
any other reason
and um i was really proud of that listen
if the militias wanted to do trash
rather than walk around with guns i'm
all for it
if they're willing to replace the guns
with trash bags we should share
communities in washington dc
and south carolina north carolina
virginia as a result of that
and when donald trump started running
he said two things that got my attention
the first thing he said was radical
islam and
then he said something like putting
america first
and then i knew right then that was a
man for the job
see we didn't hell yeah brother a
politician
elected a businessman with the work
ethics of a farmer
then he did one hell of a job who do you
think this guy is most racist
against he's a fine and he's a decent
man with a decent family and he worked
for
like for whatever reason i think deep
down he may hate jews the most and he
cares about you i don't know why i get
that feeling he's on the other side as
well
he was often criticized for trying to
give us an equitable balance
with these countries across the world
and the media would chew about and spit
them out
now they remain silent as biden
bumbles around the white house and can't
form sentences and
slips and falls if donald trump
almost slipped one day and it was
mainstream
story of the day we had joe biden fall
three times going up the same set of
stairs and we didn't hear a word about
it did we
what that shows you folks that we have
got an assault time decency it's led by
the mainstream media
and we've got to start pushing back so
let me give you a couple examples how
you can push back
please say you live in an area like me
in south carolina we've got one of the
most liberal papers in the
in the country there in the low country
the post and partisan
okay so what we've devised is we're
going to start finding out who's
advertising in these papers because
these papers have to pay their bills
weren't they against this strategy when
people did it to fox news
do you really stand for this ideology do
you stand for them perpetuating this
democrat narrative
this is what they opposed when people
did it to tucker stop advertising there
cancel culture wow patriots to believe
that you condone
this behavior we've got to hit them
where it counts because the crowd's
confused because they were like tucker
was telling me this is bad you know
what can they do to us that they haven't
already done or are they going to
continue to do
they don't like us they don't like us
because we embrace the constitution
the greatest document in the world the
bill of rights
documents
[Music]
you know there's a lot of us out there
that that haven't had an opportunity to
serve our country
but right now folks you have an
opportunity to serve your country
right to serve your country by standing
up to the radical left
and for to demand the answers to these
questions that we have
what questions why
why can't we find these about you know
when you vote
you own that vote for 22 months
[Laughter]
they're trying to keep us from what they
showed up at arizona with 100 attorneys
who shows up with 100 attorneys if they
have nothing to hide
go figure any day trump's gonna be
reinstated guys right
you know the bedrock of this country
is fortifying your household
giving your family a better opportunity
what it's for the men and women who go
to work every day fortifying your house
they can give their family that
opportunity
that's the new republican party and
that's the party of donald j
trump
and we've got to encourage him whether
or not donald trump runs again or
whether
if he's not reinstated which we all hope
he is there it is
he'll certainly be helping us decide who
does there it is
you know when we look across the country
reinstated liberal leadership that's
calling the shots
you can look at without even knowing
it's a republican or a democrat governor
there you can tell who it is
look at ron desantis in the work that
he's done in florida
let's hear it wrong desantis folks
he says the hell with those masks open
those schools
open those restaurants
you know we think about the democrats
and and they're there for the lower
income right so
and they're not going to raise taxes but
you know how they raise the taxes on a
lower income
look at the price of petrol uh petroleum
now for gas
started under trump demand-based family
and economic recovery
60 miles a day between so at the end of
the year
you're you've spent over an extra 2 000
okay so these democrat policies and
abiding are trickling down to the same
people that voted for them
so we got to wake them up we gotta
explain to them and common sense things
that are hitting their pockets
we got to talk to them about their
pocketbooks that's the thing is he's
suggesting price controls on gas who
want to give their family
a better opportunity to get a better
life they're just confused
so we got to share with them the facts
that are going on
i'm going through minnesota the other
day i paid a dollar i think
i mean 329 and gas and diesel
i was paying a dollar 69 last
year and a half ago okay because nobody
was driving anywhere dude
people are trying to get rid of oil as
quickly as they could we're in the bread
basket of america right now
okay when these farmers get hit you're
gonna start feeling it in your milk and
your eggs and your bread
and your cereal i felt trump in my
cereal this morning i admit that that's
true
it's all going up we look at the assault
on these infrastructures that are coming
in and
was it that but now the meat is shut
down and they're having a hard time with
the meat remember they shut the pipeline
biden wants to spend on infrastructure
they're practicing
folks they're practicing for when they
try to sink us
and we need answers and you need to
start saving your money and stacking it
away because
i'm not so sure the bank's the best
place to put it here we go
you need to start saving folks yeah this
is like a sovereign citizenship
we need donald trump back in office
[Applause]
you know when you're out there and
you're looking for your news
i was kidding by the way i don't eat
cereal people are worried i don't eat
cereal
other than my occasional magic spoon in
such a way that just anybody can
understand them
and it just and it is music to my ears
when i see them and i
i try to get my friends to listen to
them all the time because they're very
informed
i'm investing in pastrami things have
been able to happen to me is being
starting bikers for trump i've been in a
position to take my mother to
four white house christmas parties is my
date
so uh that was quite a quite a thing i
lost a couple girlfriends along the way
when i chose to take my mom
okay but uh it's okay because uh you
know the one thing that never changes
that's mama and your love for mom
and uh speaking of mom uh
our patriot over here mike lindell he
came to my hometown in mount pleasant
south carolina on mother's day
and we had a rally and he blew the doors
off of it they told me we could never
pull anybody on sunday on mother's day
well nobody ever tried to throw a rally
with mike lindell either on mother's day
right this little area
put over 800 people in there and it was
amazing and
the man stuck around and shook
everybody's head
and uh he's just very personable we just
can't say enough about mike lindell
i'm hoping we've got some mike lindell's
out there in that uh
in that crowd
you know he's gonna get mad at me when i
get off because you know he likes to
keep his message on point but
you know i've been able to draw some a
source of inspiration if you if you look
over here
next to our booth he's got a booth he's
got a book over there
that talks about his life right and um
as i read the book i'm now i'm reading
it for the second time because i had to
i an earbuds it's just so good to read
again it's just chock full of good
advice put it out there
and you know when you measure a man or a
woman i think that one of the
one of the best measurements is humility
and having none
okay having the humility to just
tell it like it is he talks at his book
about how the drug dealers had an
intervention
okay who what drug dealers do that i'd
say drug dealers that saw
so much potential in a person that they
couldn't stand
anymore right the drug dealers weren't
willing to sell mike lindell drugs
because he was going to do too much good
if he could get off the drugs
that he is that's amazing and he's a
source for inspiration for a lot of
people including me
he spends his own money on it mike stop
buying drugs from
men raise money spends his own money
you've got too much potential that says
a lot about people because everybody's
got a special relationship with the
money in their bill folder
the money in his billboard is like
orphan he just he spins it
he puts it out there he helps people
it's like chlorophyll he said
couldn't have been more proud to have
him there at my old campaign
headquarters he's just
quite a guy you know now we look at that
assault on decency i was talking about
with uh
with a fake book you know did he say
assault on the ethos pitch
i think we're around the hell is this
guy talking about a million
they shadow banned us they take us off
but mike lindell is giving us a new
voice
a new way to reach people and we need to
get on this frank speech
and we need to make that the number one
platform in the country
there's nothing on it you can't access
the damn thing on it
one of my favorite things
one of my favorite things is you know
what one of the only rules is
you can't take the lord's name in vain
right how about that
i'm just gonna briefly mute this because
i do want to make sure everybody's
getting a thank you who's been
supporting the stream thanks to suicide
kings for the twitch sub uh i very much
appreciate that you're number 82 today
also thank you to ali sorensen who just
signed up at joinpackman.com new member
number 83.
we have a one day coupon code it's
mikepillow50
mikepillow50 check this out he's
throwing t-shirts
low rent ron perlman throwing merch into
the crowd
do something good with this you chris
chris cox thank you
use the coupon code mikepillow50 on my
website
all right there goes chris cox all right
our next speaker
our next speaker well he made national
news
as the sheriff oh god milwaukee county
oh god clark isn't unhinged
i'm going to step away during clark and
take a little break
it'll continue then i'll be back
publicly for everybody to hear
anyone oh thanks to green man as well
green man thank you that is the sheriff
of milwaukee county he said you know
what folks
law-abiding folks better have a gun
because we may not get there in time so
he said you need to have a gun
this is going to be really bad defended
your second amendment right
weaponized he was the sheriff of
milwaukee county from 2002 to 2017.
this guy's horrible and in 2013
the constitutional sheriffs and peace
officers association
named him sheriff of the year
right of all sheriff's join me in
welcoming sheriff
david clarke is this guy seven feet tall
also
[Music]
oh my god i think he is
[Music]
good afternoon everybody
all right i'll be back guys
i love you back i love you back
i'm going to start the way i always do
when i address the crowd first of all i
want to give a shout out to our military
veterans
and our law enforcement officers all
across america give them a big hand
[Applause]
it's also important for me to point out
as you well know
blue lives matter in america
[Applause]
you know after over a year of going
through a pandemic
that we are now learning was an
overreaction to an
overhyped flu virus government has
decided
to take their boot off our necks and let
us get up off the floor
folks if we're going to save america it
has to happen at the state
level washington d.c is irreparably
broken
now that we're able to stand upright we
have to make a vow
to never again let a few unelected
bureaucrats aided by some progressive
politicians
looking to screw us we have to vow never
again to let these scoundrels
dupe us into believing that civilization
was going to end
if we didn't do something immediately
those bastards
[Music]
we allow democrats and their lap dogs in
the media to weaponize the chinese
coronavirus
and use fear to shut down our roaring
economy
close businesses put people out of work
government place us under house arrest
without due process
and seize power away from the people not
allowed by the united
states constitution
now let's examine what they did to us
without our consent by the way
first they told us to close our schools
and businesses for two weeks so we could
flatten the curve
flattened the curve they said and told
us to separate from each other and stay
in our homes and they told us to wear a
face diaper
to prevent the spread and that was after
one tony the fraud fauci
tony the fraud fauci went on 60 minutes
tv news show
and said there was no need for everybody
to go out and buy
and wear face coverings and that he
wasn't worried about the spread of covet
in the united states
some states even set up hotlines to
report
people inside their homes who may have
had friends
or relatives over to celebrate
thanksgiving
christmas and new year's eve
in fact they told us we couldn't travel
at all
they closed churches and synagogues
canceled
easter the holiest day in the christian
calendar but they didn't order that
mosques be closed
the city of chicago even set up
roadblocks
highway roadblocks to prevent people
from wisconsin
from driving into the city of chicago
all of this was done without our consent
and it exceeded
government authority under the
constitution of the united states
then after that it became about testing
we were told we need mass
testing before we could resume our way
of life
and get our god-given rights back so we
tested
and the number of positive tests and
deaths were corrupted for
democrat agenda purposes follow the
science we were told
even though there were competing
opinions by doctors and scientists on
the best remedies
tony the fraud file chief became the
self-anointed expert
on covet fauci bamboozled
politicians with his bs the american
people were hoodwinked
you were lied to by an unelected
over-credentialed bureaucrat
faulcy the fraud called any doctor
or epidemiologist who had an opinion
that challenged his
he called them a distraction some of
those were doctors who treat patients
i should remind you that faulty the
fraud does not
treat patients
but it wasn't over then we were told we
had to wait for a vaccine before we
could resume our normal way of life
then when a vaccine was produced we were
told that even if vaccinated we had to
continue to wear a face diaper
and socially distance for the
foreseeable future
then talk began about forcing people
to get injected with an experimental
vaccine
by using a vaccine passport scheme
[Music]
then all of a sudden out of nowhere the
center for disease control
changed course and said there was no
need to wear a face diaper
or socially distance if vaccinated
by the way the cdc has
one main mission to prevent
the spread of infectious diseases and
they failed
us miserably
the cdc knew of the existence of this
novel virus when it appeared in europe
and they indicated it was nothing to
worry about
so what changed from falci the fraud
saying nothing to worry about
to forcing people to get a vaccine
ladies and gentlemen you know the
science didn't change
the politics changed
the fraud was consumed by all the
attention as he took on
celebrity status every national news
cable station wanted him on
we let this group drive public policy
we let falci drive economic policy and
public health policy
people delayed medical screenings
over what fault she said mental health
problems spiked all across the united
states
with what this idiot fauci was telling
us
as you know this whole coronavirus care
became the
infrastructure for our 2020 election to
be manipulated
with mass mail-in voting that allowed
democrats
to cheat their way to a win in the
presidential election
i don't have to tell you that election
was
flat out stolen
[Applause]
president trump was right i know it
you know it and the democrats know it
that election was stolen
so let's fast forward to now these three
things
will be on people's minds entering the
2022 midterm election number one is
election integrity
number two is law and order and number
three is border enforcement and we
conservatives
are on the right side of every one of
these issues i wish i could say the same
thing
about all republicans but sadly
they are not always right on these three
issues
let me start with some observations on
election integrity
we americans need to be guaranteed that
we have
free and honest elections polling shows
polling show that americans have no
faith
that we have fair and honest election
we americans need to have more
transparency
in the voting process and that includes
poll watchers with adequate access to
see
what is going on to see what is going on
and this one is the one i think is most
important we americans
must never give up our right to
scrutinize
election results
let me stop there for a minute and talk
about what's going on in arizona that is
a good thing
i don't care how much or how bad the
democrats
criticize us for scrutinizing election
results
it needs to be done it needs to be done
in wisconsin
it needs to be done in michigan it needs
to be done in pennsylvania
and every other state where there were
election irregularities overnight right
before your very eyes
now on the topic of law and order our
police continue to be under attack
from cop-hating movements like black
lives matter
two-bit politicians looking to score a
few cheap political points
and politically active district
attorneys who camp
whose campaigns were financed by one
george soros
defunding abolishing and reforming
police
are not serious public policy
proposals it is flat out buffoonery
it is an attack it is an attack on civil
life
the rule of law law and order it has
contributed to an explosion
of crime in urban cities people
mainly black people are shot and
murdered
in eye-popping numbers
democrats in black lives matter could
care less
as children murdered in chicago is up
300 percent in 2021
this continual knee-jerk response to
every police use of force
is asinine
we don't need police reform in america
we need ghetto reform in america
this current police reform bill moving
through congress
is an anti-police bill
and no republican lawmaker at the state
or national level
should attach their name to this bill or
be in favor of it
in congress it has been named the george
floyd police reform act
[Music]
now i don't know about you but i'm tired
of hearing about
george floyd
the sooner we put george floyd in our
collective rear view mirrors
the better off america will be
everything that has been associated with
george floyd has led to
riots looting deaths
injured police officers destroyed
businesses
george floyd should not be used as a
marker
for anything in the united states
this police reform bill or anti-police
bill as i call it
removes qualified immunity that protects
law enforcement officers from being sued
personally
where actions that were made on the job
in good faith
i have a suggestion this bill should
remove qualified immunity for
judges prosecutors and all members of
congress
who enjoy it why don't we remove it for
everybody then then let's see how much
support in congress there is for this
piece of crap bill
[Music]
[Applause]
this anti-police bill takes away certain
defensive tactics
that when applied properly keeps
officers safe
a no knock search warrant has to be
approved by a judge to begin with
it has judicial scrutiny before it's
served
it must be explained to the judge why it
needs to be used
there may be weapons in the home to be
searched that might be used against
officers as they enter also
evidence can be disposed of before
officers breached the property
none of these things are going to reform
policing in fact
it will make policing harder to do
i was asked in a newsmax tv interview
what i could suggest to make the george
floyd police reform act
better and i said put it in the shredder
as i said we do not need police reform
in the united
states we need ghetto reform
[Music]
the police are not the problem crime is
the problem
the criminals are the problem
your community's finest are under
tremendous strain
they need more funding not less they
need
more resources not fewer they are
understaffed and it is taking a toll
on their mental health as police
suicides have reached
record numbers across the united states
this profession has a higher has higher
rates of suicide
than any other profession where is the
empathy
for our law enforcement officers
here's the ugly truth george floyd would
be alive today
if he had complied with the lawful
commands to take him into custody
[Music]
officers tried to place him in the rear
of the police cruiser and he would not
go in that move right there would have
saved him
instead he resisted arrest he was geeked
up on fatal levels of fentanyl
at the time of his death the police were
called because he was trying to pass
20 counterfeit bill to buy more drugs
i refuse to elevate a guy who once held
a loaded firearm to the stomach of a
pregnant woman
and threatened to shoot her in a home
invasion robbery
i refuse to make this guy an icon in the
march for civil rights in america
ladies and gentlemen this is a national
disgrace
it's a disgrace to dr martin luther king
jr
it's a disgrace to rosa parks it's a
disgrace to frederick douglass booker t
washington and others they weren't
criminals
now i want to touch on border security
there are three main reasons why
a country has to have effective border
control
if you're going to be a country you have
to have borders and you have to be
willing to protect those borders
here's the first reason why you need
effective border control
you have domestic threats and national
security threats
you saw that ms-13 was freely coming
across our southern border
you saw that terrorists were freely
coming across our southern border
the second reason you have to have
effective border control
is to prevent the spread of infectious
disease
i cannot believe that the biden
administration you notice i didn't say
president the biden administration
open the southern border
with no concern for kovit
none zero how can you do that
during a pandemic because they just
don't care
the third reason you need effective
border control
is you have to control the influx the
heavy ink
flux of another country's near do wells
you have people coming into this country
there's a language barrier they don't
speak the language
they're not educated they don't have job
skills that they can offer to an
employer
our system our economy cannot handle
that
our schools cannot handle that all of
these schools don't have bilingual
programs which cost
money where's the money going to come
from these aren't things
that these smarter than anybody else in
the room democrats
haven't given any thought to let someone
else figure it out as their attitude
president trump if you recall implored
the gop at the time control congress
in 2017 to get him an immigration bill
that he could sign
he laid out a four point plan i thought
it was sound
neither then speaker john boehner nor
paul ryan or
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
moved on anything about border control
or immigration
when they lost control of the congress
in 2018
they left it for the democrats to shape
border policy
now we are back to open borders
if you recall president trump was unable
to get funding from the board for the
border wall through the normal process
to the gop-controlled congress and he
was
forced to declare our southern border a
national emergency
so he could take funds from other
defense departments
to help build a wall and seal
our southern border that was with a gop
controlled congress
the now democrat-controlled congress
passed a bill to stop trump's
declaration of a national emergency
every democrat voted to nullify the
executive
declaration and they were joined by
13 gop members in the house
think about that that included
wisconsin's own
mike gallagher and james sensenbrenner
who's now retired
keep that in mind in 2022 if you know
people that live
in gallagher's congressional district i
think it's somewhere in the brown county
area
in the gop controlled senate after the
president declared
the southern border a national emergency
13 republican senators voted with
every democrat to try to nullify trump's
emergency declaration
if the gop controlled congress would
have given president trump
the funding that he needed through the
normal process
he would not have had to go the national
emergency round
how's that for having the gop on your
side
now i bring this up for a reason next
year is a
midterm election year sure it's
important to regain control
of congress from the democrats right now
we have to rely on
joe manchin and christine cinema to save
us but i don't want to have to rely on
two democrats
however i am not willing to help the gop
retake congress
without a pledge by every gop candidate
up for reelection
that they will support president trump's
new
contract with america
if they will not then we need to find
candidates who will support the contract
with america
and primary those who will not i don't
play
party label
i'm not saying it's the worst thing in
the world i consider
democrats and republican the political
class
the ruling class neither party is really
on your side
they certainly weren't on president
trump's side when he needed them
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to get the wrong people off the
plane
the right people on the plane the right
people in the right seats
and then we can take off
we cannot skip this step ladies and
gentlemen i don't care how many election
cycles it takes
otherwise we will get the same
establishment
swamp behavior we saw in congress when
donald trump was president of the united
states
that to me ladies and gentlemen is
untenable
[Music]
it's why i'm doing what i'm doing now i
started a non-profit
a grassroots individual advocacy i find
that the individual doesn't have a seat
at the table of state government when
legislation is being crafted
if you're not a part of the donor class
or you're not part of a special interest
you have no seat you have no voice we're
going to organize
these individuals at the base level the
voters
and we're going to take state government
back rise upwisconsin.com
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen it's go time it is
time
to once again make america great again
[Music]
god bless you and may god continue to
bless the united states of america
thank you
[Music]
all right sheriff clark
now you know what's happening at three
o'clock central time right
president donald j trump on the
jumbotron
so that's coming up at three
and then keynote presentation by mike
lindell
now don't forget we are live 24
7 at frank speech dot com
and we're also live with our tv show
every night from seven
to nine pm central time and we've been
interviewing a lot of great guests
we've got more shows coming exclusively
to frankspeach.com
but every night monday through friday
and then again on sunday seven to nine
we're live
from the news desk where we filmed all
of our documentaries right there out of
the mid-south
so make sure you join us each night
seven to nine central
because we are interviewing just so many
incredible guests
and we do long form interviews so we can
really get to the issues
well our next speaker up she's in her
twenties
and we need more young people don't we
speaking up
about the issue of life and liberty
she is a pro-life advocate all right
guys i'm back what did i miss
about a very vital issue of course she's
an
author she is a speaker
she does uh videos her videos been
featured by
prager university was the sheriff racist
she's an ambassador
with turning point usa we are so glad to
have with us will you welcome
danielle dinesh
gill danielle danish gill
isn't it danielle de souza gill
is this is this the national zoos
daughter her
wife danielle de souza will you welcome
her
is this his wife her daughter lower the
mic there how are we all doing
[Applause]
we're ready to hear from president trump
and let's give it up for mike lindell
who put together this huge event
people all over the country are watching
this today
yeah i also want to give it up for
dinner more on this stream actually
i had to go first so he's a great
great guy great dad so okay anyways
thank you guys so much for having me i
just want to talk about
a couple of things um i want to talk
about the censorship
going on right nobody can speak ever
and also the indoctrination of our youth
of young children of
um primary education yeah by the way i
wanna i
based on the diamond and silk screed i
did research the price of mangoes
a nine or eleven dollar bag of mangoes
is actually a pretty good deal at most
grocery stores so i don't even know what
they're complaining about mangoes are
not cheap
okay guys the more you know and
everything that they're targeting
it's so focused on the youth it's so
focused
on changing the next generation so
that's really what we need to focus on
so i just want to start by saying a
little bit about myself i grew up
as a conservative i was christian going
into college
oh no but i wanted to go to a liberal
campus because
i wanted to talk about jesus and
my goal of going to college oh my god
evangelism it's
uh bringing people to christ who don't
know him so many young people
are very lost so she's found a lot of
tables we did so many events
brought so many people um to christ what
a brave thing to do to see just the real
darkness
just the evil going on in these
institutions
so many professors there are focused on
brainwashing
these young students who really are
unfortunately unable to hear
from a lot of conservative speakers
they're unable to hear
a lot of the other side and so as i went
through school
guys she found people had been edu had
been indoctrinated by education
so she went to fight that by telling
them about
jesus beyond it's just
um as soon as i started supporting
president trump and my school was in new
hampshire so at swing state so really
wanted to get out as many people as we
could
and i tweeted something saying uh i
voted for president trump
but the lord is king of kings right and
that set off this huge firestorm without
trump's high but
but jesus is high um i got questioned by
my teachers i got kicked out of
every other you know club i was in and
um
when i was questioned by some of my
teachers they would say you know how can
you
you know support such an evil you know
racist misogynistic person and
i would say you know the fact you know
that's my dad you're talking about
who president trump even actually is is
just so sad and so just talking about
him
was so shocking to them because they
live in this eco chamber in this bubble
and i actually told them i said the
founding motto of our
of this college was box clemantis in
deserto which is lone voice in the
wilderness
and the fact that you are persecuting
someone who's alone voice in the
wilderness just shows how far you've
gone from your original mission which is
which was actually christianity
a lot of these schools were were founded
by people who
wanted to bring uh my school at least
american indians to christ
well things have changed so far away
from that what's her name daisy dinesh
d'azuza
in a classroom there are two
types of people in america there are the
people who uh who love america
like thomas jefferson they actually
mentioned my dad is a modern person who
loves america
and then they said on the other side
there's um those who hate america who
know it's
evil who know it's racist so the
students who believe
they love america go over here and those
who hate america go over here
right and so all the students went on
the side that said they hate america and
i was the only one
um on the other side so that never
happened
i was really shocked by that and but i
think that so many people around the
country they just don't see
how when we start out with these because
they hate america
people end up growing up and they
graduate and they go into the world they
end up becoming reporters at
you know washington post they join cnn
they end up owning
businesses they join these social media
tech companies to cancel us
and so this culture on the campus ends
up emanating out into the real world
they join antifa
all of this they join so um they've
joined
college i've said you know i want to
join the trump team
there's almost no antifa women for trump
we traveled around the country doing the
bus tour the pink bus uh got to meet so
many young
young ladies and other people and
brought them over
uh to uh the trump campaign and i think
just seeing how
how fearless president trump was and how
he was never afraid
of the media he was never afraid of his
critics
and so i think seeing that was just so
inspiring because
i think so much of the time we we don't
see people fight back we don't see
our politicians actually you know speak
to the people who support them instead
they try to speak to
the message i'm getting overall from the
speakers is
we're constantly the victims of
everybody
not letting us speak not letting us
espouse our ideology
um we are not only godly
but we are moral and we are good and we
are smarter and we are right
um and why can't they just let us do
whatever the hell we want
all the time that's that's the message
here he said you know i think we need
more we mean
we need more brave young people out
there and i said well do you ever
get afraid you know do you ever get kind
of
um does it ever get to you the criticism
of the left
and i thought of course he'd say no it
doesn't get to me but he said it
sometimes does
and so then i said well you have so many
people out there who
will never give up on you and um
i think just knowing he's not going to
give up
trump that's not who he is he has an
undying courage he has undying
faithfulness
to all of these forgotten men and women
of america
and so i think that was the most thing
to me about him was just that he speaks
for
every forgotten man and woman who is on
the campus who is
um out working they're just completely
censored and silenced
and just goal of the left to go after
youth indoctrination i mean they're
putting out
so much pro propaganda to make us
believe that
there are no gender there there are
no gender identity outside of your race
all of these things they're pushing on
young kids who don't know anything about
any of this
and we need to shield them from all of
this so if you're able to join a school
board or you're able to fight back
against this
we have to do this in our local
communities because
um there are so many of us who who can
speak up and
people always say you know what can i do
how can i speak up against this but you
actually can there are so many things
that we can do to stop them and i know
most americans they're not okay with
this they're not okay with this
happening
most u.s americans in california and new
york parents say this is gross this is
not okay we can't allow young kids to be
brainwashed like this
um and i also just quickly want to talk
about
abortion right and how the left is so
focused
on nine-month abortions they've become
so radical
no one wants that for them to have any
limit on abortion
and the fact that mississippi is in my
entire life
i can tell you with 100 certainty
i've never met anyone who's trying to
increase the number of abortions
i've it's i've never ever ever ever come
across such a person
as governor ralph northam in virginia
talked about who's buddies with biden
that they can still be kept comfortable
and a discussion will ensue as to what
will happen to them next
uh governor cuomo he's lit up the
freedom tower pink to celebrate nine
month abortions for no medical but it
was kumo
no life of the mother or complication
yes they've appropriated this as a
women's issue as if this is good for
women
when in fact it harms so many women and
if you're a woman who says
that you're against this or you
regretted that the left cancels you
they want absolutely nothing to do with
you because they like to celebrate
abortion
and make it nobody celebrates it um
something good for women they even
sometimes argue it's good for the baby
to be killed they will say things like
this
child is better off dead if they're poor
this child is better off dead if they
have down syndrome or whatever it may be
and as we know every single life is
worth fighting for every life is worth
living
it's not up to the left to say a life
isn't worth living
they shouldn't get to decide that now of
course
if they if a fetus is a person
um then they would never deport any
pregnant undocumented immigrant right
because
there there's if if it was conceived in
the united states then it's a u.s
citizen at conception and
they would always say never deport never
ever ever deport a pregnant woman we
would never do that
um the left has really i think realized
that this issue is a losing issue for
them yet they continue to dig in on it
and they've already basically planned
for the supreme court
to either overturn roe v wade or roll
you know
the truth is more americans than at any
previous time think abortion should be
legal in most cases so i don't see how
you can say it's a losing issue i don't
hear the left really talk that much
about abortion at this point
because it is legal but the country is
more on the side of abortion mostly
being legal
now than it has ever been before to act
like
everybody does but they don't and i
think if we really think about too
just what it means to be an american who
is our next generation these are these
little babies and
they are the most silenced they're the
most censored they're the most
voiceless in our society and so we are
really the only people who can speak for
them no one else will speak for them
um and president trump was you know one
of our most pro-life presidents we've
ever had
speaking for life pro-choice till age
68.
became pro-life six months before
running for president to that issue
supported susan b anthony list so many
things and so
i think we need to keep that in the
forefront of our minds and that
this is a life and death issue and you
know it's not like politics is over here
and our our faith is over here our faith
has to influence
everything that we do and our
relationships our work
and our our life how we vote for all
these things
because it affects life and death it
affects human beings
um and i think when we even look now to
where we're going from here i think we
we can only look
back to a time when things were in so
much turmoil like they are today and
that was when abraham lincoln civil war
he said without god's help we cannot
succeed
with it we cannot fail so we need to
keep prayer
central to everything we do all of our
actions what is this speech about
we are doing that for the lord and i
just want to end it on
the words of president trump which is
that the best is yet to come
thank you wow what a disgusting speech
danielle de souza gill
thank you danielle wow horrifying
well do you think her dad is proud
you want to know why she's so sharp
she's got a
father that has been leading the way in
the conservative movement for many years
you'll see where she gets disconnected
from reality as an exchange student
and he was named one of the
up-and-coming young people
and you know his hey real quick just to
catch up on some thank yous thank you to
nug wrangler for gifting five subs as
well as
uh slingblade and great job spaghett
ignae and baloney try
try kill eric and fearless freckles
uh very much appreciate that putting us
at a really strong 91
also on the website coupon code
mikepillow50
only today juliet smith nick has just
signed up on my website also want to say
thanks to maria braver
who just used the coupon code
mikepillow50
and jill sobel using the coupon code
mikepillow50
absolutely love it let's get now to
dinesh d'azuza oh my god this is
horrifying this guy is disgusting i'm
just warning you get the kids out of the
room please
[Music]
wow this is incredible
wow yeah
you know i don't think i've ever spoken
at a rally before this is awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a reason for that the hats
the enthusiasm this is fantastic hey um
you know i was i was 17 years old when i
first
saw america right
i was an exchange student from india i
came on the airplane in initially into
jfk
and i kind of remember the airplane
descending and i looked
exhaustedly out of the window and i kind
of saw the skyline of new york i saw the
statue of liberty in the distance
and i thought to myself even then when i
wasn't really thinking politically in
any way
i thought to myself dinesh your life is
going to be very different from
this moment on how many lives could i
ruin in this country
you're moving from the margin of the
world
to the center and you're coming to a
country
that is different than other countries
later i would understand that you know
historians call this american
exceptionalism
but for me all what american
exceptionalism meant
is that i was coming to a country where
if i stayed
i could become the author of my own
destiny
and of his own propaganda books
i could become the the architect of my
own future
i could be in the driver's seat of my
own life
when when we think of america we think
of
opportunity we think of the great
material
abundance of america and i did see all
that
in fact i was um i was placed to live
for the first few months with the host
family
this was in patagonia arizona a small
town on the mexican border
and my host family says oh dinesh we
planned all the sightseeing for you
we're gonna take you to the grand
canyon we're gonna take you to the to
tombstone arizona the site of the
gunfight at the okay corral
and i was like guys you know i'd like to
do all that but
the kind of sightseeing i have in mind
is i'd like you to take me to
the supermarket because i want to see 35
types of cheese
and 40 types of ice cream
[Music]
you know the the rich guy lives anywhere
lives well
everywhere in the world one of the
things that struck me about america is
that it
it's a country where the ordinary guy
can have a good life
health care
and it isn't just about it isn't just
about making your life better or having
more
it's also about the notion that in other
countries your destiny
is to a large degree given to you hey
guys i do want to briefly interrupt this
disgusting screed
apparently um there has just been an
attempt to hijack
an airplane there is video of it and
what we know right now
we'll look at the video in a second the
man made an announcement that we needed
to be close to our oxygen masks and
proceeded to try and open the door
they then called all the strong men to
the front of the plane
to restrain him we ended up landing in
oklahoma city
he was trying to open the door to the
outside not the cockpit
look at this just happened
absolute chaos this was a flight from
lax to atlanta right now
get them down
now fortunately it would be extremely
difficult to actually get it open in the
air even if you knew how to do it
uh the force on the out the door is
built in a very particular way
where if i recall correctly the the
pressure pulls on the door and you have
to open the door
in and at altitude it would be
extraordinarily difficult to do
um but the guy was was taken down and
grabbed we i'll look for more
information
um about this but that that was the
latest that i've heard now we all have
all the same information
back to dinesh the sting of this america
myself when i stood up in a courtroom
and i heard the following phrase
united states of america versus dinesh
d'souza
whoa zoozow no immigrant wants to hear
that sound
and then as i began to deal with these
i would call them obama lawyers
in other words there are lawyers that
are part of the southern district of new
york this is the very outfit that's
going after trump
by the way headed at the time by this
asian indian guy named preet bharara
whoa asian indian waiter i call him
but these guys i realized uh were not
interested in any kind of justice at all
they were like dinesh did you exceed the
campaign finance laws i'm like you know
what
i was trying to help a college friend of
mine and so i did
oh so you broke the wall i expect the
same penalty as anybody else who did
the same thing and they were like not so
fast
uh we're gonna get you on bank fraud
i'm like bank fraud they go yeah because
you took your money out of the
your bank account i go what
they say we're gonna get you on mail
fraud and i go mail fraud and they go
yeah because you put your check
in the mail whoa and i was like
i turned to my lawyer and i said what's
really going on
and he goes what's going on dinesh is
that these guys
these sons of [ __ ] if i can call them
that
they're taking the same laws that were
passed to go after
isis and the mafia and they're using it
against
fellow american citizens why
because from the perspective of obama
and the people around him you're not a
critic
you're not a dissident you're not even
an immigrant who doesn't understand
america
you're an enemy and they have to take
you out
that's their psychology and little did i
know then this is going back to 2012
2013 that all of this little case of
mine
would then be multiplied a hundred fold
and we'd see it with general flynn we'd
see it with papadopoulos
they were all sandbagged guys it's all
unfair well
what is it it's the gangsterization of
the left
and who is the head of the snake how did
this start how did we get this
america you know it started with obama
right everything was fine he is the
snake
[Applause]
now the reason i say this is because
before
obama i'm not saying that the democrats
were doing great
but the democrats were sort of in the
jimmy carter mode
and jimmy carter i think if you were to
um give an award
for presidential ninja poopery
to the the dumbest most ineffective
president certainly of the 20th century
i think jimmy carter wins hands down
what a great speaker may say well
actually he's getting some competition
from biden
because here's another guy who really
doesn't he's he's sitting in the canoe
are we in the 21st century
i don't think he even knows there is a
canoe this guy's really boring
so he moves his mouth but most of the
time if you look at his eyes
they're vacant he's staring mindlessly
into the distance
he's in a sense a ventriloquist doll
and others are manipulating the strings
but coming back to obama probably antifa
holds
my great sin really was not giving
twenty thousand dollars to my college
buddy wendy long
my real sin was to take on the most
powerful man in the world
this vindictive narcissist obama in the
white house
by making a movie about him the movie
was a disaster it was
one of the worst movies
and to give you an idea of what a low
disgusting nauseating character this
fellow is
[Music]
it's it's really his hypocrisy that i
think i
expose most of all because here's a guy
who's been going around he's still going
around doing it
we are a brother's keeper
the fact of the matter is this is a guy
who doesn't lift a finger to help
anyone in his own family in the movie if
you saw 2016 obama's america
i interviewed obama's brother george who
lives in a hut in nairobi
in conditions that resembles slumdog
millionaire yeah really explosive
interview one of obama's aunts died in
kenya
this is actually his father's sister
and the family had to appeal to kenyans
to provide money
to donate money for the funeral
a couple of years ago i was in my office
in the king's college
and i get a call and it's from obama's
brother george obama
and george says to me dinesh he goes i
hate to call you
he goes but my little son who's at the
time
six months or nine months old is very
sick
could you please send me one thousand
dollars
and i had met george obama when i was uh
interviewing him for the movie so i'm
like george
and he's a little bit of a shyster so i
said george
hospital now he goes yeah scheister's
anti-semitic
send the phone over to the nurse and
then i asked the nurse i said is it true
that george has a son
and he's very sick and the nurse goes
yes it's true
so i said george i'll send you one
thousand dollars by western union but
before i do that i have one question for
you
isn't there someone else you can call
oh no apparently the connection to
[ __ ] is not
accurate no it's not clear it's not
clear barack obama
this is who he is but he hates to have
it pointed out because if you do
he wants to go after you and the good
news is that even though
i was a little dumb
i was a little naive
[Music]
i shouldn't have realized there's a big
sign on my back
the simple truth of it is they took a
bunch of shots at me
and i'm still here
imagine being at this thing i would be
so bored just say they tried to silence
me
and it didn't work they even tried they
even tried to give me mandatory
psychiatric therapy and that didn't work
it didn't work that's true it definitely
failed yeah
i agree and then in the summer of 2018 i
was at home
and the phone rings and i pick it up
it clearly didn't work it's trump
[Music]
wow he's like hinesh
i'm here with um john kelly you know
john kelly don't you
i'm like no
i know who he is but then trump says
well you know i gotta turn to your
your case he goes i gotta tell you from
the beginning
i knew it was total [ __ ]
and i was like and then trump began to
talk about my case but i realized
i wasn't even listening to him because i
knew what was happening
what was happening is that this is a
weird story
i was about to get a presidential pardon
which would give me all my rights back
and i can vote again
[Applause]
but even more important was what went
and this is kind of interesting about a
conversation the things that go unsaid
and what went unsaid he didn't say it i
didn't say it
we both knew it is that in the act of
doing that
trump knew and i knew
that he was delivering a giant up yours
to the obama administration
right that's actually all that trump
cared about
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy's really thirsty huh and then
he basically said dinesh listen um
don't tell any to anyone about this
until i tweet about it in the morning
which brings me to the issue of
censorship
because look
[Music]
i did not believe in the america that i
came to in 1978
that we would be at this point in which
we have seen
a sustained assault
not just on our economy we're not just
dealing with the kind of socialism that
reaches into your pocketbook
undermines the currency through
inflation
it's funny confiscatory biden has
literally changed nothing about tax
policy yet how could it's it's already
socialism dinesh was all about
class warfare
and the democrats are practicing class
warfare by the way
not on behalf of the poor against the
rich but on behalf of the rich against
the poor
on behalf of the elite against the
ordinary guy
that's their class warfare
but it's far more than that
they have unleashed gangs paramilitary
gangs on the street
antifa black lives matter
all of this is done in the name of
justice what justice
anti-fascism
now look okay i'm not scared of these
guys
anti-fascism these are basically misfit
kids coming out of mom's basement
complete losers hey mom
where's my halloween costume i'm gonna
go find some fascists
dummies but
they're not gonna pick on somebody who's
their size
[Music]
they're gonna pick on some they're gonna
go to some restaurant and harass the
people who are eating over there
are they fascists how do you know they
burn small businesses they torch
churches
he's having an entire bottle of water
and by the law the law needs to teach
the law needs to do to them what their
parents didn't do
which is grab them by the lapels
and hold them accountable
now it's one thing to say that academia
is rotted from the core it is
it's one thing to say that the media's
rotted from the core it is
these people are habitual liars
they're not biased they're not mistaken
they know the truth but they conceal it
i'll give you an example a concrete
example
in my own case several years ago
[Music]
a reporter trying to do a hit job on me
and this was digging into my past when i
was a young renegade at the dartmouth
review
in my college years i'm 60 but we're in
an age where people attack you for what
you did when you were 20.
and so this guy goes when dinesh was a
student he published an article
in which he said the question is not
whether women should be educated at
dartmouth
the question is whether women should be
educated at all
which i confess is kind of funny
except i didn't say it
some other guy wrote this in an article
and it appeared in the dartmouth review
but it wasn't my word so like this is
depressing by the way this was a purely
surprise winning writer
[ __ ] field of the new york times
notice that i always like to name
names
and so i i thought indecency let me just
call up fox butterfield and i'll say hey
mr butterfield
you just got it wrong you tried to score
a hit on me but you missed because
i didn't say it and fox butterfield goes
well
you wrote an article about the dartmouth
review years later in which you quoted
that line
so you did say it and i said
if i said it by quoting it you've now
said it by quoting my article
but what i'm whoa is that this guy was
so duplicitous so shameless so utterly
lacking in basic journalistic integrity
and he's a model of the profession he's
at the top newspaper
in the country well i think we now
realize what we're dealing with
with media we're dealing with people who
are
hitmen for the left that's how you have
to look at them
and so my simple recipe for the media is
do not believe anything they say
even when it's true now this may seem a
little shocking for me to say
the crowd's already doing that so even
when it's true
but here's my reasoning let's say you
meet a guy and he's a habitual liar
75 of the time he's lying 25
percent of the time he's telling the
truth who the hell has the time to sort
it out
he's a liar don't believe one word he
says even if it's true
and the same is true of the media
whatever they say
don't believe it why because if you
don't believe it you're likely to be
right
most likely you'll be right once in a
while you'll be wrong
but they'll leave trump instead what
trump says you can believe really
important by the way
it's really bad that we on the right
have let the left develop this monopoly
on the institutions of culture
the media hollywood the entertainment
industry
but now we see how aggressive they are
how
discontented they are they're not
content even though they have almost
you think they'd be like wow we got
academia we got the
we got the elementary and secondary
schools we got the media we got
hollywood
that's enough no they want the nfl
they want the boy scouts they want the
music industry
they're even going after these
corporations the woke corporations
one of the things that i find in terms
of censorship it's not just
digital censorship right yeah that's the
tip of the iceberg
and look how fundamentally dishonest
these digital sensors are
basically if you if you follow the
fouchy emails
look at the way in which he was
communicating with zuckerberg
communicating with bill gates he was
communicating regularly with chris cuomo
at cnn
why because that's spouchy he's a pr
guy and he's all about controlling
the discourse fauci knew you can tell
from his emails
that hey the virus might have come from
the wet market
but there's not one iota of evidence to
this date that it did
none nobody's tested wet market guys and
shown that they had the virus
before anybody else the chinese won't
allow that kind of testing
the virus probably came from from the
lab
and it was probably made in the lab
i don't think there's no evidence of
nothing i mean they take these deadly
viruses
and they make them more contagious there
is no evidence
and so and this is done by the way with
support of people like fauci
who are funding american labs that do
the same thing
and work in collaboration with wuhan
so what happened is when they realized
that there was a global epidemic however
it got out
and i'm not even ruling out the
possibility that it was a biological
weapon it was deliberately
released there's no evidence of that
though you think the chinese are sort of
too high and too moral to do that see
what's weird about this is
he says you know fauci didn't present
evidence
that it came from the wet market and so
we shouldn't believe that
and he says could be a bio weapon all
that he's not presenting any evidence
for that
and absent evidence to believe that
wouldn't we believe the simplest
explanation
remember how the chernobyl accident shot
down the whole nuclear industry for a
whole generation
they realized that's going to happen to
us and so they realized not only do we
have to
pretend that we didn't do it it's kind
of like a guy who's
it's one thing if you make a mistake and
you hit somebody on the highway
it's a whole other thing when you do you
use you do hit and run
and then you say let's go wash the car
let's take off all the traces of blood
and then you go one step further let's
blame it on some other guy
let's let him take the responsibility
that's what's going on here
and so what you see here and it's very
dismaying in america
as i say it's one thing if it's media
it's one thing if it's academia
but who who knew that our health
agencies were corrupt
he's got a rap who knew that our police
agencies of government my
idea when i was a kid of the fbi was got
was gotten from the movie the
untouchables
wow these are guys going after the mafia
they're taking down the bad guys
no they are the bad guys
yeah they are the bad guys and you know
why
because a thug with a badge is a lot
more dangerous than a thug on the street
a thug with a badge comes with the
authority of law
madam would you open your door here's my
badge
and so corruption at this level should
be punished five
times more than corruption of the
ordinary kind
says who what is this guy talking about
yet you see in case after case that
there's
no accountability at all
now censorship
i noticed it's reaching a totally new
level when i made the movie trump card
which is the latest film great film oh
yeah i've seen it by the way
it's worth watching it's based on my
book united states of socialism
it's terrible and that's where we're
headed
we're headed to caracas we're headed to
venezuela we're headed to a society
in which if we don't stop this we will
see total breakdown
very bad but interestingly when i was
making the movie trump card i noticed
that all kinds of people who had worked
with me before
people in hollywood big movie houses and
producers people
suddenly hate now that they know me they
hate me all of them
backed off when they saw the word trump
trump's name was sort of radioactive
we the company that made the trailer for
the movie infidel
terrific people great trailer they're
like we'll make infidel
we won't make trump card we're out
when the movie came out trump card did
suddenly you found
it was supposed to be up on amazon prime
you couldn't get it
you got it eventually but really close
to the election
thousands of people ordered dvds they
were like out of stock on day two
even though they had the dvds so what
you have here
is a new phenomenon which is even the
institutions of commerce
at one time when i studied economics you
get the idea that these people are
motivated by
my business they want to make a profit
they want more customers
they're motivated by money no
you think jack dorsey is motivated by
money
he has a lot of money he's motivated by
ideology
he's probably also been motivated by a
demented psychology
these guys i mean you would know dorsey
he's not a normal person he hasn't had a
normal life
he probably wasn't treated as normal in
high school
so these are guys who were treated as
dorks and nerds
and weirdos because they are dinesh was
the cool guy in high school that's why
he's so normal
zuckerberg's a robot
and what you have is these guys now
about four of them
unbelievably are controlling the public
square and the public discourse of the
united states
of america that's a fact
that's a fact and people say well you
know even on the right you'll have
republicans and this is the problem with
the old school
is that the old school republican or
even the reagan republican
doesn't realize we're not living in the
reagan
era wake up we're facing threats
far more serious than we did then and so
the strategies that work then
don't work now yeah the crowd's dead so
stop acting like rip van
winkle how long has this guy been going
do we know
so what's happening now is that there is
an effort to shut
us down there's an effort to turn us
into worms
that was the point that george orwell
makes in 1984
there's a scene that i recreated in the
movie trump card
in which uh the hero this guy named
winston has been captured
by the state the socialist state it's
called biggs big brother
and big brother the interrogator
representing big brother a guy named
o'brien is trying to convince winston
to admit that two plus two is five
dude the crowd hasn't read the book man
it's this is not the crowd for
literature
yes you are two plus two is five say it
and winston goes listen you've taken my
money you've destroyed my family you've
taken my house you've taken everything
from me
but the one freedom i'm gonna hold on to
i'm not gonna give it up
is the freedom to insist that two plus
two
is four yeah
[Music]
and so they grab him
and they do to him what they're doing to
the january six protesters
solitary confinement psychological
torture
sensory deprivation no food he starts to
have hallucinations
wait a second and he breaks down they're
denying the trump rioters
food and they're not
they're doing sensory deprivation this
is the first i've heard of that
five can i go now please go
and here is where the plot really takes
off because big brother says in the form
of
this guy o'brien he says uh no winston
you can't go
why because in your mind you still think
it's for
in other words we the state are not
content with you publicly saying one
thing and believing another
you have to believe what we say inwardly
and so we're going to continue to
torture you and break you down
until you give not just outward
but inward ascent so this is really what
socialist states are after this is the
true meaning of tyranny
because it doesn't just crush your body
it also crushes your soul
it crushes your soul now
are we going to let this happen in
america yes or no
[Applause]
no and we are in the position
to stop it in all kinds of ways
we just have to realize we just have to
realize
that this is not the peacetime
civics book debating society
politics of the 1980s
rather we have to do to them what they
are doing to us
this is soul crushing i agree
during the civil war early in the war
around 1863 lincoln decided for the
first time to deploy black soldiers
and the confederacy outraged by this
passed an edict a law that said any
black union soldier captured by the
confederacy
will be shot
this would not by the way be the fate of
white soldiers who would be normal
prisoners of war
but black soldiers would be executed and
when this came to lincoln's desk
he issued what is now come to be known
by historians as the order of
retaliation
and the order of retaliation is very
simple
for every black union soldier executed
against the laws of war yeah it's
actually hard to imagine
a worse lineup of just nonsense
it it's it's completely
vapid meaningless nonsense of
of the highest or lowest level i don't
even know
how to describe it it's it's just drivel
and the crowd is like
they sort of seem into it but they also
kind of don't i guess there's just
nothing better to do in
new richmond wisconsin i don't know i
don't know how i'm doing on time
it's your way over what you want to do
is talk a little bit about
where i think we need to go oh no in the
years ahead
oh god because a lot of people naively
think
yes we should send speakers to the
universities to try to
turn them around you can't turn them
around
they're too far gone
let's try to make movies in hollywood we
should i do
but hollywood as an institution is
aesthetically and morally rotted
it's gone you want to watch a movie
go watch an old movie
watch a movie made by a hollywood that
at one time did love america
watch a movie that celebrates heroism
and family
and patriotism and individualism
not the not the sick let me get caught
up just making sure i'm thanking
everybody
afro thunder and bowflex man grabbed a
twitch prime subscriptions which i
really really appreciate
i also want to say thank you over on my
website
william bishop the third just grabbed a
membership with the coupon code
mikepillow50
it's a one-day coupon code carlos
gonzalez
grabbed a beautifully discounted
membership and leonard
ursory leonard ursory also
signing up with the coupon code
mikepillow50
at least we're turning it into something
good because it is vile and disgusting
what's going on here
it's called anti-americanism is actually
a healthy moral response
against these sickos zikos
now censorship i think we've got
this is the issue of all issues
because it's not happening why
because voter fraud is one thing but if
you can't even talk about it that's a
whole other thing
right and
the very fact that we can't talk about
it makes the whole thing
let's just say a little suspicious
right it's kind of like it's kind of
like and
the same is true by the way of these
voter integrity laws
the left's reaction tells you everything
you need to know
it's kind of like if i have a maid that
comes over to my house once a week
and suddenly i noticed that my wedding
ring on my watch has gone missing
i'm like i wonder if it may take it meh
goes no i didn't take it no no no
so i say okay you know i don't know but
what i'm going to do going forward is
i'm going to make sure i put my watch in
the safe
and what i'm going to do is also have a
couple of cameras so i can kind of see
what's going on in my house when i'm not
there
right and one of the main response by
saying oh
no that would be racist
it will reduce my incentive it will
reduce the incentive of people of color
to come and work in your house
now i'm like i'm a person of color this
has nothing to do with race this is
something to do with my watch that went
missing last month
so the intense opposition establishing
reasonable methods of preventing this in
the future
tells you makes you smell a rat
it confirms your suspicion that
something very bad
must have happened because if it didn't
they'd be all for the audit come take a
look at the votes
let's do five recounts maricopa we
welcome it
they're scared of maricopa because if
maricopa falls
arizona falls if arizona falls georgia's
next
that's why they're scared this is wild
now the crowd's into it
now the crowd's into it five recounts
can you imagine
yeah do six who's gonna oppose number
six huh that's suspicious and
for the press it's all about playing
this little namby pamby game
so like right before i come up here i'm
cornered by some guy you know
i'm writing in an article for ruling
stone
i'm like so he's like
do you endorse mike lindell's theories
i'm like i need to see what the hell has
been going on
i want the facts and what annoys me
is a i don't see adjudication of the
kinds of things that people are worried
about
if you want to have a democracy where
people believe in the system
why not have open adjudication well
people are making a lot of baseless
claims
well the claim is only baseless until
it's adjudicated
then it has a base man
so let's see that's all i'm saying i'm
taking the agnostic position
i want to see
[Music]
the problem with these guys constantly
claiming they just want to see
they're just asking the questions is
they'll never be
we've done all of this stuff already
we've done it they will never be
satisfied and i did a really good
interview with andy norman earlier this
week
good in the sense that he was really
good in it not patting myself on the
back he was just really good in it
where he explains that the there's a
difference between
healthy skepticism and unending cynicism
which can be weaponized and that's
exactly what they're doing here
and he's weaponizing it while drinking
just liters of water
have a namby pamby way so we say things
like you know
i don't like what disney's doing i'm not
gonna go to disney
all right i'm gonna cancel my
subscription to disney plus
we'll do it then nah they don't care
about that
what you have to figure out is how you
can do something
that causes them intense and repeated
pain that's what you have to think about
now
a couple of years ago in 2014 2015
i published a book called america
a defense of a kind of rational
patriotism my
my motto was the motto of edmund burke
who said those books are so stupid
should be lovely anyway my book is out
there it's doing really well
and suddenly i get a call from you know
there's so many interesting things to
read like i can't i've got a stack of
books
i just read red notice by bill browder
i'm reading blitz scaling by reed
hoffman super
interesting about rapidly scaling
businesses and
there's there's just so much in anything
with philosophy
who would go and read this guy's book as
what you choose to read it's got to be
people who don't read anything else
right i can't even imagine
in my book so it could be that there's
some store manager that's like mad and
like
let's move dinesh's books in the back
he's like no
your book is unavailable in any american
costco in the whole nation
costco and i thought to myself wow how's
that gonna happen he has a right to sell
in costco is for the ceo
or somebody very high up to give an
order pull this guy's books out of
costco
how does that happen think about it the
way that happens is like this
the ceo of costco is a huge obama
supporter
so what happened and i'm only inferring
this but it's going to be something very
close to this
okay so he doesn't know a guy someone
you know he has no idea
rahm emanuel no evidence walks into
costco he admits oh my god
there's dinesh's book let's make a
couple of phone calls
and so costco very eager to please says
okay mr emmanuel
okay mr whoever we'll pull the book
right that's what happens
and there it is and you may think that's
it what else can we do because
adjudicated corporation tens of billions
of dollars
well here's what here's i want i'm
giving you the story because it shows
kind of the way to fight back yeah so
what happens is this journalist who
called me writes an article on a website
it's a small website it's called
worldnetdaily
and he exposes this and people toxic
conspiracy websites 1000 people
raging against costco disgusting website
world net daily website
yeah that website is costco and couldn't
care
less but
then somebody in that group had a
brilliant idea and this is the kind of
idea you should spend half your day
thinking about
right and the idea is why are we raging
on world net daily let's all mosey over
to the costco website
and let's trash the costco website more
cancelling
they're supposed to be against this
stuff because costco does a big chunk of
its global business off of its website
right so what happened is this little
snowball begins i'll leave bad reviews
on the one ply toilet paper that costco
sells
really him where it hurts guys and these
people were
a little pissed because
not only were they complaining about my
book but they were going to every single
costco product on the site and
announcing that it sucks
the food socks the clothes are horrible
they're cheaply made
and they would post photos of themselves
cutting up their costco executive hey by
the way costco sells clothes
i've never been to a costco do they sell
clothes i didn't know that
now this is what i call activism why
because it is a direct kick they do oh
interesting wow
literally once this happened within one
day
i get an emergency phone call from
costco the ceo
wants to fly me up to seattle to talk to
me one-on-one
emergency ticket i go up there
and i kid you not the little weasel is
actually crying
oh he's crying and the first words out
of his mouth is dinesh
you are destroying costco
[Music]
i'm like could this be a real story
billion dollar corporation
not bad not bad who's next
so so
anyway brian i'm almost done
so basically please get off the bottom
line of it is i said to him i said hey
listen i'm not trying to pick a fight
with you
i said you have antagonized your own
customers
what kind of a businessman are you a lot
of your customers are conservative
why would you take a patriots book out
of your store on the fourth of july
what kind of business judgment does that
show and so i
i left i i left on good terms i flew
back to san diego and literally by the
time i landed
costco had reversed this decision not
only did they put my books back
but they constructed a giant standee so
when my movie came out
i had hundreds of dvds exhibited all
over costco
[Applause]
and and in all honesty
i've had excellent relations with them
ever since
i wasn't out to get them i was just out
to reform them
right but the way to reform them is to
make sure they hear you
so when it comes to disney plus when it
comes to lockheed
when it comes to all these corporations
he called maryland luckily
they hear you they're not the lion
you're the lion make sure that they hear
you roar thank you
leave fraudulent reviews to get
attention is the message from dinesh
d'souza
[Music]
there he goes
wow what a sweet what oratory
did he also say that they were doing
something with bvds
oh my god he's back
[Applause]
why is he back if i can say one brief
thing before i leave
i'm not doing a daily podcast guys oh no
i do it in audio and video
it's on audio on apple spotify google
it's on apple video it's on youtube it's
on rumble i'm going to put it up on
frank's
it's on orange and bananas it's my
chance i've never had a regular podium
but this is my way every day to identify
the left identify the bad guys
and give it to them thank you very much
there it is uh didn't ever he's never
seen a grift you didn't like
dinish all right we are
about an hour and six minutes
from the keynote presentation of two
great keynote presentations yet to come
donald president donald j trump on the
jumbotron and then mike lindell
right so we're excited
well our next speaker he is a
all right we're going to test some audio
all right hang on yeah all right guys
listen that's going to do it for me
i've done three and a half hours that's
about all i can take i do need to take a
mental health break
because i do think i i just dropped
about four iq points during this thing
so if you really want to keep watching
this you'll have to do it i guess on
frankspeach.com but that's going to just
do it
i can't do any more i don't think we're
going to learn anymore
but if the trump speech is wacky i'll uh
i'll i'll clip it
and talk about it on monday all right
guys it's it's just too much
it's just too much so uh i apologize to
everybody if you want a mercy ban
you can ask for it and uh we we may we
may accommodate okay everybody we'll see
you guys later thank you for joining me
real pleasure having everybody